[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good morning
on that fresh new sunday time
let me know how my levels is
[Music]
what's up hustler motivate what's up
appreciate you brother appreciate you
good to have you on the stream we're
gonna get you back into round two for
real for real hustle you know what i'm
saying next below what's going on east
texas alex what's going on lloyd metroid
next good to see y'all pressure that
sunday morning service
gerald mack my man what's going on
because of our heart you said let's talk
about that sony domination over here you
were looking spooky early don't fret
that absolutely though
what else we got what else we got a lot
of people pycon
fusion what's going on good to see y'all
early you know what i mean
you say yeah yeah we got to see how it's
going in jd
[Music]
talk to the people
what's what's going on guys man i i i
look bad it's 11 a.m my sleeping
schedules messed up so uh
you know what's funny my sleeping
schedule is messed up
to what
[Music]
is
[Music]
3mg in the building of dolphins i see
you that's okay a lot of football hustle
got his dc that washington football team
okay
no doubt you already know folks about to
eat i know i know anyway so we'll see
you in a minute we're gonna get 3mg fins
okay wow everybody got the teaser
football is back everybody pumping 18.
this is what everybody thinks they hit
it that's why we do it at 11. that's the
main reason because the first half of
the year
everyone thinks they in it and then by
new years everybody get eliminated in
the real teams
raiders g-man okay okay
everybody throwing these teams up let's
go
all right we're gonna talk to y'all
we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell the uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you were messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social my city but
[Music]
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
um
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we were
messaging people on
[Music]
that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boil you
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
an uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
[Music]
but i'm gonna be your dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look
gotta mess up and turn me to an animal
and haters be swearing they real but
come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
you i always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when
um
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
attic if i can imagine it's cool to give
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny work to
cognito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that you can't even still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in a crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we
are love
welcome to the iron lord podcast llc and
also live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 224 and it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day nice fresh time y'all i'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got playstation
showcase impressions mid-generation
refresh rumors and halo infinite
multiplayer flight to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose amazing
integration of video games humor and pop
culture is clearly a result of his
tremendous talent and impressive
partnerships all done with that pure
passion on the grind
introducing the creator and host of the
3mg gaming and 3mg live youtube twitch
and facebook channels
the lord of storytime fitness and the
cell squad who thanks to jake paul is
now rocking that full hair dye all fleek
oh no do rag a hotnet bro
new york new york and making his debut
into the realm of the lords
my man lord ricky aka three mg live how
we doing sir i know i was one of the
best angels you kind of gasped me a
little bit man i'm like damn
it's a pleasure man um
like i think addict mean addict we've
been uh cool for a long time you've been
trying to get me on here for a while and
i'm just like yo i've been wanting to
get on i love podcasting i love talking
games i talk a lot so pleasure man i
really love it i can hear you with
whatever questions i'm just going to be
100 honest i'm going to get ready but
make sure you hit that like button on
the channel man real talk
let's get it popping though
glad to have you around you putting it
down for a minute brother it's only
right made the call of like of course of
course we got to get through your boy
man oh gee right there you already know
we're going to get into it but like what
you been playing man what games you've
been playing what's going on with you oh
you know you know this whole all this
streaming stuff it kind of takes away
you know so i try to dabble in between
like so many different games i jump back
on to like the master chief collection
because this beta is dropping like i
think the 24th they said so i'm like let
me get my let me get my skills right
before then you know and then um
obviously i've been on pc a lot of times
ain't really not for me to play on on on
the playstation as a recent i haven't
really been on that too much 2k drop
been playing a little bit of 2k trying
to get it to that but mostly just been
playing like some just pc games just
about a bunch of party games because you
know i'm streaming on twitch so um life
is strange came out i'm trying now
but
uh just trying to think off the top it
ain't nothing major okay there's nothing
like no major major is that this is that
your first life is strange no no have
you been playing the series i played the
series um so far it's a very slow start
right but you know me and my boy uh
shout out to my boy chase of gmg man uh
chase yeah that's my brother right there
oh man we had them all yeah yeah man and
and the first thing he said we was
laughing is like playing this life is
strange that ability is just not it you
know i don't want to know when when the
homies is down bad that ability
other than that yeah no like off the top
i mean i've been i play games all the
time but right now my time's been
fulfilled by by like 2k just because
it's something new but i'm waiting for
that battlefield waiting for that
infinite to drop
the drop so that's been kind of like i
saw
i saw you playing a game on stream it
was like they're like the these little
rubber balls and like they had like this
streak attached to the vehicle
yeah yeah yeah it's a party game i think
you should play that drunk with your
friends
it's frustrating and fun at the same
time and then it's like one of those
again party games with the homies is
always the best time you know i mean
maybe one of those man yeah you already
that's what's up man hey sorry if you
want to get that little super chat came
in before we get yeah yeah we have uh
robert
that's what it sounds like five dollars
have you seen the tweet about god of
wars boat animation by gandalf gaming
the knees were flying yesterday
very messy investigation we're gonna get
into all that
we got all the stuff we're gonna take
care of and you already know we got
waiting for this man
yo you know we got the four horsemen of
gaming those originals around here at
the round table little 11 a.m time
sensitive intros we got to respect
ricky's time you know what i'm saying
but of course we got my co-host with the
cobos my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good first thing i want to
do is i want to make an announcement uh
for those of you that know i've been uh
i've been pretty like
like
in and out on switching people out on
the attic show because i wanted to find
someone that has like a really good
chemistry to me and i finally found my
man
that pause
[Laughter]
my new co-host for the attic show from
here uh for into the future
it is
he said sir with a question
i said pause hustle
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
anything you've been playing sir i've
been playing bravery default too okay
you know i'm really enjoying it
but man i'm i'm really considering just
like buying this on steam and play it on
there because that switch performance
just ain't it man it's not hit and say
lagging
damn that's crazy that's great so does
that that's what's going on yeah that
that's pretty much about it uh i've i've
been playing a lot of hades uh i'm
actually really
hating on hades
we was talking about that in the chat
the other day
so what's funny is like slow slow story
time like me and king were in a party
play and i was playing hades and i was
talking snap about the the the the
the one the the the goddess of love so
i'm like man
yeah she's
like
she weak man
none of her abilities are any good so
then you fight this like the third round
boss and then once you get his health to
a certain amount he summons a random god
and it was hard
okay
of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the lord of clarity
and lord patron of the iron bank my man
fresh off that brazilian rodizio lord
sovereign how we doing sir
good morning gentlemen
he liked that he liked this lady he
liked that morning time he liked that i
gave you the straight poo poo yeah yeah
what's good man it's been a couple of
weeks man since we've been we've been in
the realm so i'm back been a minute man
so yeah
not a lot of game in the past couple of
weeks just uh catching up on some uh
marvel shows because i knew i was gonna
go see sanchi yeah yesterday so i wanted
ketchup
so last week and i were at the last time
media event was absolute fire big shout
out to everybody on the team over there
dustin ben maddie colin like everybody
man everybody was so awesome um it was
it was amazing it was an amazing amazing
time so that was that was fantastic
and shout out to my taka killed it you
know
i did not agree with the subject
i was preaching that mass effect 2
goodness
let's go so and of course last night
hanging out with the boys man shout out
to a belated birthday said lord marlon
yes
happy birthday brothers
shangti was a beautiful beautiful movie
um
and really man like
i did not think i would enjoy this movie
as much as i did uh yeah it's in my top
two
of uh origin stories it really is you
know what's
funny like that it was nice
last when i watched it last week i told
cog i was like man i was like
it's up there with doctor strange and he
knows that's like my face
yo it is the best hand-to-hand comeback
[Music]
no that alone just really just declared
that statement because i like i need to
go see that movie
last week we went you went last week the
seats was absolute garbage i said now my
buying seats up close
so we ended up watching like candy man
you know i still like the film but i
need to get i got to get this movie
going gotta get bro
okay i'm sorry no no for sure like it
was it was really like everything like
like king said like the combat was
amazing yeah but we're going to talk
about that are we doing it
okay we're going to figure it out we got
it we'll figure it out i'm down i'm down
everybody's seen it we got it
[Laughter]
so you remember you can you remember
that they used to have they know the
lovely lady walking around with a little
car and she used to you know shake it up
none of that anymore
it's coming right from the bar yes and
it's twice the price it's twice the
price oh no no no no no i want
entertainment for you
to set up shorty so you know
right like you're writing something and
you know
yo we all saw that price when they when
they brought the check around
and dude started you know you know it's
bad when dudes are okay so i had um
you know what
i had but i only had two
that's what you do
kind of like kind of like get real close
let's look at this oh
yeah because the thing is when you get
when you get past a certain amount of
people at the table they just put the
tip down that's right they're like no
this is the minimum you're getting
they're probably like really secretive
with that so like you double tip on
accident you don't even know it like oh
yeah
you see gratuity yeah you already know
what it is
percentages yes so that's what it is
yeah that's been it man no gaming i'm
excited uh we got we got death loop
coming we got a couple other things
coming so i'm excited
i think it's next i think it's
i think it's monday or tuesday
are you serious it's nothing
i think it goes live midnight tonight i
think oh okay
no it's tomorrow tomorrow night
okay
tuesday tuesday morning man i gotta i
gotta i gotta dust off the ps5
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the excess gamer oh
the prophet of xbox one
king of the statues if there's nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
oh beloved lord king how we doing sir
i'm doing a little samba i'm going to
give a sleeping piece to uh my brother
my fellow king
my boy chris uh he passed away
unfortunately at the young age of 32
years old wow
uh he went into a routine surgery
came out of the surgery
posted the pic like everything was okay
everything is good
and
things just went downhill so
that's what cut you did was i did i meet
him at the no
no okay he he he lives further out but
he's trying to get to us but you know he
lives further out um but that's the
reason why i got cable up there he's a
huge x-men fan and um and in tribute to
him i put up cable so i'm gonna you know
with my brother
to the whole dcx fam i saw the chat
everybody seemed very surprised but i
know he was close to a lot of people so
yeah we um we did a show last night uh
go check out legion the doom on the d6
channel uh we did a tribute show to him
on uh friday night uh at 9 00 p.m so
um
no doubt but anyway uh
get a little bit more reckless now i've
been playing
the artful escape
okay
i i can't say it enough about game pass
you know um
stuff like 12 minutes the awful escape
the art of driving uh these games uh
that you would normally never buy like
i i'm not you know captain i would never
buy these games
but the fact that they pop up in game
pass i'm downloading them
you know
there's no sweat off my back to download
you and un uninstall you if you ain't
right
you've got five minutes to perform
i like you
i
show me what you got
and and it showed me and showed me
exactly what it had and i'm like wow
this game is really good so i'm bouncing
between that hades psychonauts too
psychonauts too
it's like fine wine okay
you know um tim did his thing you got
you just really gotta sit down and
absorb
that game in his entirety you know wifey
was listening to
some of the things that he was saying
like there were conversations
and she was like that's
looking at the game like what they're
having deep conversations like that it's
a kitty game with deep undertones yes
there's a lot of games that have been
dropping like that too yes yeah and and
the mental health mental health yeah big
benefits
i love it it gets people in shout out to
my man t4 oh what's up my man
let me tell you something
all right so the day before
it was on friday i went in there with
him and cog
in trials now he called me that morning
and said yo they fixed trials up we're
going to get into trials let's get this
work yeah
got in the trials and got smoke like a
handful
everybody was clowning me
oh you you you running two primaries you
you don't
first of all when a dude tell you you
got to go get your guns together first
of all he clowned you right so i said i
i had to sit with that in my heart
i had to rub that in my chest like some
paper roll
it was disgusting i had to walk with
this in his soul there's nothing because
then what's funny is
uh uh ricky's been playing a lot of that
here recently
they were talking about like the whack
look at stuff i was like oh we called
that walmart
with the walmart pve guns so my behind
go to work
on friday let's go friday night
it's in my soul while i'm working
i'm hearing people clown me in my head
your guns ain't ish
what you doing bro why did you throw
that riff there the better question
the better question the better question
did you hear it in tax force you you
heard it in everybody's voice it was
harmonizing it was like a barbershop you
were attacking my head it was
they were they was taking tag teams
on me
so okay
i get back home nine o'clock in the
morning let's go i see him on
in a party by himself okay
i jump in i said what up homie what's up
what's good pull back up he said he said
he said what would you what you trying
to do
i said i'm trying to get this trials in
let's go okay back me and him
two man team two-man team with the match
matchmaking fire
flowless i saw that yo i put in so much
work like
you know what he told me he pulled me to
the side he said yo
i'm gonna be real with you
you a hell of aggressive dude right
but you're playing like a [ __ ]
wow that's what he said okay he said you
standing in the back you don't got my
back he said yo i want you to treat it
like if me and you was really going to
wall
that's what he said just like that he
said i want you to treat her like me and
you really going to war
what gun would you grab
if me and you going to war
and you got to get my back
okay i grabbed my crimson old criticism
i got my my confluence okay i took uh a
heavy duty i don't cause i don't worry
about it don't worry about having that
one around for the time i went in there
pistol popping
butt cheek rocking
dudes dudes what that work
yo it was a part i got goosebumps on the
part
both of my teammates is down here those
are the clutches yo
it's two dudes out there oh
his i can hear him take a deep breath
like damn he's gonna fail again yeah
we're gonna lose this round i threw my
riff down oh you did my i had an ark
buddy yes snitch i jumped in the air
i saw a dude going this way i threw my
grenade that way right before he was
about to move i popped him two times in
his head he got weak he he walked into
my grenade that's what's up you down i
saw his boy across the room i pulled out
my confluence pop-pop twice and then i
pulled out the crimson and i finished
more i said let's go
first time in all the years i've been
playing see the flawless i'm jealous i'm
not even flawless bro i saw it i was
like oh you know what's funny did you
know i saw that and for some reason i
felt like travis helped him do that
i was even i was even i was even extra
salty yeah i was like
this man travis did not come out of
nowhere and help king go flawless but
i've been sitting here and waiting
way that tito was sleeping bro yeah i'm
gonna talk about that real quick real
quick um so
king i gotta ask we gotta have some man
talk with our favorite fighters
it's done for him oh so the real deal
abandoned himself
a legend in the game gave us some of the
most iconic moments
yeah um
i don't know what's going on i don't
know i don't know how the bank accounts
look i don't know what it is i don't
know what it is
he needs to see outside still at 60
something okay so first of all
when dudes see mike tyson come back
then mike tyson get in the bag and they
see roy get the bag yeah you're right
you know these dudes are looking like
it's checks out there i don't care what
you say
you know you're gonna look up and say
excuse you you got checks out and then
you see the checks that they getting
yeah i fought that dude i beat him why
is he getting a check no you got to add
me on today
yeah you're right you're right you ain't
been working out i don't care but you
gotta add me knock me out for that 50
mil let's go and and he they saying jake
paul and these dudes get out that's what
i was about to say king you know what
they're saying they're like they're like
look man you might be loaded you let a
youtuber fight let me know
i'm not i don't agree with it because i
know what brain damage and stuff like
that does the fighters
um
but yeah let's keep it real
these dudes didn't have any real
management with their money oh in fact
yeah
and they had they got their money early
not now when you have all these
investment options and all this other
stuff
and they blew through the cash i'm
looking at pacquiao taking a beating
with this young dude for no reason
and you're supposed to been right after
that floyd fight dudes get the floyd
fight and never fight them
[Music]
we got a lot of stuff going on oh sorry
get a couple super chats before i go
sure okay we got let's see that we got
hustle and motivate two dollar super
chat shout out to the panel and 3mg um
we got
cheney five dollars super chat king
psychonauts 2 does the same
multi-dimension thing in one of the
later levels the ratcheting clan could
totally be done on ps4 collect those
this is true i told you all ahead of
time but i mean they're both really good
games no doubt i mean technically
homeboy said that could be done on the
ps3 with wings
yes the pull button we know
five dollars in the chat happy sunday
lords absolutely listening to the
podcast we're on my weekly three-mile
hike up the mountain over here wow see
you there you think sid that's what's up
i know i like
exactly also on that health and wealth
grind no health as well
i'll be doing it
there we got tony bryant 5 super chat
good morning happy to be here live 3mg
with the great energy as always
iop goes great with coffee mass effect 2
is go eyes
oh yeah i'm glad you read that i'm glad
you got that right
tales of a rise people
you don't agree with that either
it's not even that man i i don't i don't
like these people getting used to this
11am thing already they like they like
it that's good
be good we're good playthings
temporarily hashtag go birds
that's 16 weeks of of yes no no we got
two january that's what everybody team
is out of contention then we get back
okay
then we got slow mo back slap five
dollars to be attacked morning lords
nearly 20 clears in haiti so far working
on the epilogue that game is fire i want
to see supergiant do the next ultimate
alliance game yeah that is a
guy i like that i like that i like that
what else then we have la boogie
haven't been here in a while but came
through for king's playstation slander
let's get started
but we got ricky to balance the force we
got ready to balance the force on that
i'm not gonna let you down i got on my
booboo the fool uh
we got it it's gonna be some fun it's
gonna be fun all right all right we good
we're good we caught up yeah of course
we got the game ninja himself the
shinobi lord cognito spreading that
realness into the rubber iop not telling
what you want to hear what you need to
hear shout out to the filing dude my boy
maddie plays shout out to last stand
media everybody that pulled up show love
your boy never signed autographs before
in his life that was crazy that was
crazy you know what i'm saying so look
to everybody that pulled up yo the whole
team colin dustin chris dagin i mean the
mayor you know what i'm saying you had
the man out there got the key to the
city like bro like i don't even know it
was a magical wicked soft pulled up the
love the homie love i mean just
everybody like salute to everybody
tremendous you know what i'm saying
obviously duke will be up later catch
that the live show will be up at some
point i'll let y'all know but yeah shout
out to everybody that that meant a lot
your boy your boy almost you know what
i'm saying when i was on stage you know
it was a live audience hits different
you know what i mean so salute to
everybody iop
you know the crew everybody came up oh
and shout out to the people who was in
the crowd with ilp shirts y'all yeah i
was like yo we listen to y'all some
people are like yo i've never even heard
of you
and i'm gonna listen to iop now you know
what i'm saying like that that's love
you know what i'm saying so they're like
yo king they see some is that soft is
that hair that's what you know when
someone pull you up
it's insane that's a weird feeling but
um but you notice like kind of scary too
it's scary but you you notice the impact
you have on people like and that's why i
tell people guard your words yeah facts
guard your words and stuff that you say
because you don't know who's watching
you who's taking your lead guard your
words i'm gonna have to go extra
episode trials episode talk to that
guy
guys in his feelings right now because
charles is popping he thought it was
gonna be some major disaster completely
wrong but we will flame him on the last
word coming up and of course shout out
to ben smith we gotta uh we did the 12
minute spoiler cast that's up that'll be
up on their channel so check that out
but look enough for all that one most of
the time we gotta get into it um we got
what's it oris we got horace yeah two
dollars super chat did jimmy dance moves
look sad to y'all at all during this
show yeah yeah why he got the job
we finally got all the intro all the
lord stuff we've been playing we gotta
focus on lord three and [ __ ] his video
games
his journey into content creation and of
course what led him to starting both the
amazing 3mg gaming and 3mg live
movements so lord 3mg let's start from
the beginning man what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
so
you know everybody got like they're like
they're kind of like story with oh i
started off with this console i i
started labeled consoles because we
didn't have the money to like kind of
get our own that's what i kind of got
into it like when i was what seven eight
because i would we would always go over
our family's house
and you know the aunts and uncles
because they always had like the 64 to
sega genesis
nintendo so i started off i think one of
my first games was contra hardcore
that was one of my first games and i'm
like just playing it addicted like
what's this and then you know every time
we would come back home i'm like man
what do we do now
every weekend every weekend they go back
he was playing that teenage mutant ninja
turtles
i remember just it was like we would go
to upstate you know and i was when all
the family and it sucks because we don't
really have that no more like as we get
older yeah we you know coming together
it's like that's why i take these things
so serious podcasting getting a discord
call with everybody and just we all
vibing because that's the closest that
we now get as yeah in fact i paid a like
bigfoot going somewhere for the weekend
so that was where i would get all my
experiences from and um that's kind of
the early on stages i was playing uh
streets of rage with my older brother
and then one day you know mom's just
popped up with like
a ps1 and um
we had our dream cast we had our stuff
like that but it was always difficult to
get games and then honestly i gotta say
i'm grateful for even just how demos
were back in the day yeah
demos were demos
we don't get enough so like the memos
held me down it was to the point where i
promised myself as i got older if i was
able to save money right i'll just get
myself into it oh for real and it's a
thing because like we we have our
backlogs is crazy you know
because there were so many games we
couldn't play when we were younger just
due to the financial situations but that
got me into it and you grew up where
where did you
you're raised in these areas i'm
chilling with a lot of my friends as i
got older but i was always behind the
scenes playing video games
again so why they out there freaking and
wilding with the chicks i didn't have
the money to go chill out i'm like yo
where am i gonna get money from 14 15.
you know
yeah
i mean it was there there was avenues
but but it was a different chose a
different way yeah man shout out to you
for choosing a different one yeah
actually yo we laughing the peer
pressure was crazy yeah no no doubt
because i always like i knew when
something was wrong because i was able
to identify with these uncomfortable
feelings like i would be playing like
and this is real talk like this is why i
have like a passion for just all
consoles you know what i'm saying
because then when i had the ogx box i
just it takes me to a place of being in
like the garage with the homies with two
tv
and and i'm forever grateful for that
because that group of friends right
there were the ones that like they
didn't feel comfortable going to do
certain things outside right
no we we took advantage of that and at
that time we had that the gameboy
advance sps you know we had like
different music gaming i thank god today
man because i could be doing something
different so you thank god for your
gaming click right yo
because see people don't realize in new
york or wherever you're at in the world
i mean everybody was a little bit
ostracized at that point in time
especially from the females and from the
so-called cool dudes oh you playing
video games what are you a child or
whatever man
you know so yeah you know to to get past
that stigma you linked up with your
homie like you see him pull out a game
boy or something you're like yeah
yeah even at times i would be like 15
and like 14 i just entered ninth grade
and i was still chill with like my 13
year old friends
like the older guys they were already
like trying to get like they were
forcing themselves to be too much one at
the time i'm just like all right i mean
of course i was into the ladies i just
got into high school but it was always
like a
oh man but if i'm going to do this i see
them doing things like smoking done yeah
yeah in my deal like i'll have my glass
of wine my drinks of course i get busy
but as far as like the other stuff
entertaining and i just knew and then
having a strict mom by herself raising
me and my older brother who everybody
got to say yeah that's great hey man and
it's like that and it's unfortunate
living in major cities like
yeah that does not help so
yeah and i can honestly say and i could
admit i used to lie a lot back then
trying to make it seem like
i wasn't like i had this i had the money
but i chose not too fast i don't care
what to say now if a woman or or a male
friend be like i can't hang with you not
about like okay all right whatever
that's fine with me i'm proud of what i
do man
i look back at a lot of homies i went to
high school with and it's super
unfortunate because of where they had in
their life and i'm just like that
direction you used to be that guy back
in high school
now it's
[Music]
when you got yourself together and you
choose but it's unfortunate when i see
some of my old friends i call them
friends but also like i keep them at a
distance
you know what i mean real talk that's
real i don't even go back to my old
projects
you know they they they have like uh
melrose day and stuff like that i love
you dudes um i love the space that y'all
in but i i can't go back there because
it symbolizes something to me
some symbolizes a place i never want to
end up in again
you know so from coming from that you
know people don't know what the project
was in new york city like
other places i'm not going to act like
other places didn't have it bad yeah you
know but i'm just talking about personal
experiences from the people i know and i
grew up with so i know you in the
queensbridge type of area i go to lefrak
city every day
exactly so you know what it is yeah yeah
right so that that area where i'm at in
queens i'm all up and down queens
because i haven't caused a lot of
business yeah because i have businesses
in queens so you know clients so i go
see my clients all the time but i go
through some of the roughest messed up
areas of queens and it always makes you
reflect
you are from these areas my mother
always told me you're from the projects
but you don't got to be
of the project
so elevate your mentality to take
yourself out of the project and don't
come back yeah it's real that's right
there's a space there's a certain space
where
i don't know what it was it's like it's
like almost saying late bloomer right
like right and for whatever reason even
when i was 20 21 i made poor decisions
financially that put me in bad debt like
it was so bad and thankfully just never
taking that extra extra inch that could
have gotten me locked up or something
right and games was just my my i know
it's cliche
it's really like a thing because i was
just home once i had access you know
once you had that small part-time job
making seven dollars an hour working in
um by reference projects and yeah
rock let's go
you know what i'm saying and that's a
dangerous out there when when things
were poverty and everything so like i'm
i'm forever grateful for that you know
yeah just that's why i like i ain't go
live when i when i tell people i could
talk about games all day i may not i may
not play every single game right i may
but i but i'm always sure as hell open
to listen hear it out when i see anime
guys yeah get so geeked out yeah found
them yo like yo we could be doing
something totally worse right now i
don't care like i i like appreciate just
all that stuff but i don't really
rockaway is like those people that be
like you know awesome that's a weirdo
stuff you know
downplay i'm like yo man we're not doing
that we're not doing it yeah you play it
man so i'm i'm just like again even
being in this podcast being a part of
just being able to have access to this
internet is every place where you got to
take advantage of it this is going to be
a blessing too all right so man
let's let's say this right
when you started getting you're working
that job
what was your first console you broke
with your bread
um mines yeah that you went out with
that you said cause you know we always
you know we build ourselves up to that
space so we can able to to go get our
you know
somebody can buy you something but of
course what you what you did with your
money what you plucked down with your
heart because when we put that money on
the count there's a different look that
we get yeah it's a different look a
different like you also like proud like
yeah because yeah
yes so crazy enough i you know remember
when the 360 came out the psr three came
out right i had i was you know um and
and uh step pops at the time they gifted
me a 360. i was like wow what the hell
like this is amazing right and then the
ps3 came out like a year later or so yes
i was gifted that too but then i had
just like in as unfortunate as you know
me and i mean whoever knows like major
cities sometimes people don't grow up
that fast right
by the time i got my first job i was
like 18 19. okay
no so my first console i went back and
bought another 360. and another ps3 and
and not because like it was on something
like oh i need to do this for myself it
was like you know i kind of burnt out
those consoles at the time
but like nah you know what now i put
that money together i bought another set
of two i bought myself the psp oh yes
i'm getting myself right with all those
games and just knowing that i can now
openly go out and just go buy these
games when i won yo
power bro
that's why like that's why like i have
like i can't pick and choose which is
better yeah i just they both bring me to
certain places oh yeah yeah yeah no
doubt that's love bro i want a solution
because uh yeah a lot of stuff you said
resonated you know saying obviously you
know with the gaming being kind of like
the safe haven you know coming from new
york we already know how it is outside
and like at the end of the day like what
you would say like you had that dudes in
the garage whatever the tvs or whatever
y'all you know what i'm saying those is
the homies right yo we already know
those is the homies exactly and it just
it just keeps you out of that stuff and
they're great i'm sorry to say something
the funniest thing when you do like the
system links is like
separating the friends on who's good and
who's bad
okay
we can't have attic b with sage because
then that's going to be uneven so he's
going to have to be on the other team
facts
halo 2 on system like man was just
crazy absolutely to the part what king
he was mentioning like you know
buying the first console you know
finally being able to you know say okay
that's me you know what i'm saying don't
get me wrong i got gifted everyone you
know i got gifted at some point but
there is a distinction and what really
resonated what you said is like you know
my situation is well coming up like damn
you know one day when you don't got the
bread but you you're like yo one day
road i get the money i'm gonna get this
i'm gonna get that like you get your
little list man yeah mentally you know
it's really it's crazy man we kind of
like imprison ourselves to like the
environments we have we're just chilling
doing just stupid things and it's like
man you look at it today you guys got a
brand thank you yeah yeah
like that's the next thing anybody ever
tries to downplay that you know what
just hey they know what you know yeah
what what i tell cog is
because i was the bad boy right well
that
there was some stories of e3 yeah
there's no problem with that man yeah
exactly but i heard the very first time
i heard king pull up he was like you
better not you but you're not looking
down
just saying that you know um
individuals thought that
our connections would be bad yeah
and i just i love the fact that every
sunday we get to rub it in their face
you know i just i do and it's not going
to matter when i when i say it i'm just
saying that you were completely wrong
about how much we love each other and
careful true
you really are were completely wrong
about how we kept each other sane yes
you understand so those those people
that feel that way i post on a page like
i link them
like when
i put it up like if i see you on
facebook and you about how you do it
tune in right
because
all that stuff that you thought was not
gonna amount to nothing it amounted to
something and you know i i would have
never met attic if it wasn't for gaming
and i mean him bonded separately yeah so
it's it's like
that stuff i is invaluable you know life
lifelong friends and i'm meeting a
friend that i'm going to take with me
to the end of my life tell us
my friend until
this the show was done in my show life
acts you understand nothing not this
in the chat look who's screaming early
early
listen man i told you the lord's been
the league to football we understand
brother let's look to see you in there
you already know 9am on the west coast
of the west coast
early
that's what i've been saying forever you
know though
but we got to focus now obviously the
content creation and
the youtube and then like what was the
inspiration to finally to get you into
that space and then obviously you have a
unique situation because it's like
you've got the game but i'm scared
you're going to set up attitude you take
your business is outside
i put this business up you thank you sir
so like i said so like in your case you
know you've got the gaming and you also
got the live which is like pop culture
so how what was your style what inspired
you to get in the content creation
um
honestly uh
not being well versed at the time
like several years ago like a few years
ago not being able to articulate myself
properly with people but always being
into games i've met a gentleman just in
black ops 2 in a lobby his name x chase
money
this was like eight years ago like eight
years ago 29 now this was like eight
years ago wow and he was just like no
kind of funny i was like yeah and mind
you this was at the time where people
were still recording sometimes with like
uh
roxio game capture in the hub
oh yeah yeah and people don't even know
like this gaming stuff is still in the
infancy stage but at the time that i
wanted to do this obviously i was like
how do you do it i don't know what you
know how to and that's why i like the
channels to be honest with you like you
know i wish we knew the information now
that from back then because i could have
probably taken more care of those
channels right but basically that guy
like i i don't care what people say i'll
always thank those who
saw something in me because while people
were telling me you know you know the
gmg podcast people was telling me i'm
telling him like yo man kick him out he
told me oh he talked ratchet he don't
know how to talk he keeps cursing every
side um every sentence yes and at that
same time i just acquired this job at
the hospital work for mental illness so
i was like in a psych ward
and he was the only one that was like yo
rick i want to talk to you i think you
should start a channel you should really
get yourself going because you're a
really funny guy you play these games
um but also you need to like make sure
you don't overly like you know because
you know you in new york do you come off
again and i take that i take that in
because some people can be stubborn some
people don't want to listen some people
just don't want to take that information
and at that point in my life i'm like yo
man what do i do and i'm like you know
what i really do want to start this
channel up and you know it took years of
it so 3mg live was originally like games
as well um i want to know a funny story
my name came from being exposed because
i lied about an xbox game that i thought
was trash
wait wait wait wait wait let's break it
down break this up so three of
technically that's three minutes
break it down yeah break it down
ramsey live came later because i was
just well honest because the name itself
i said it doesn't really stick for me so
i was like all right omg live
the three minute gamer started one day i
was like man killing instinct is trash
ah f killer instinct killing this thing
is corny
it's not as gory as i thought it was
gonna be it's a coin again and somebody
just put up a screenshot
and i said dude you talking all this
trash you only played it for like three
minutes oh that's where they got you
damn
and chase and then some dude wrote it in
one of my guys terry shout out to terry
he was like yo you're just a three
minute gamer at that time i didn't
really have a good name for myself it
wasn't on youtube i have a name that was
sticking and chase was like that's your
name
whether that name might be the corniest
i just love the story behind it because
that's when they were like you see rick
you're going to get tested
you know like when you go to these
events they're going to ask you
questions you can't you can't run around
these questions if you ain't played just
say you ain't play it
like and that's what kind of like that's
right got me in it and then i started
trying to up the content more yeah and
if you guys know now i do twitch full
time yes but that took me out of my job
like i was you know thank god i was able
to resign from that during covey during
a very wow okay very hard time you know
and um
i don't know can you say you from you
from new york right yes sir so you know
so you know how the workplace is over
there you know you got upper heads that
try to like downplay people and it's
probably in other places
at a point where
last year um that's a ramble on my new
boss was like oh why you
why you get the best schedule and i'm
like i've been here almost nine years
like this is just a smartie and i never
like being confrontational at this point
i'm i never try to start any problems
with people
uh and then one day she's just trying to
throw me in the mix in the er with covet
going on and everything i was
wow and
with with chase and other guys like uh
some guy i know named pg and everything
they do so he was like yo you need to
get like on push you need to like you're
you're a really great dude man we've
been friends for a long time get on
twitch and show who you are and that's
and crazy enough years later last year i
was able to like really identify myself
i don't care if i say anything sus yeah
i love everyone man i love having fun
you know what the homies you say a funny
joke
i don't know why it took so long for me
to find who i was
meaning like meaning like uh like me
like i didn't like years ago people used
to say why are you trying to talk so
like professional like right right be
you that's what i mean like identifying
right you know you don't need to be fake
to try to get the attention of devs like
thank you yourself and that's why i get
along with everybody you know like and
but obviously you got to carry yourself
of course oh yes of course of course and
that's the separation because at the end
of the day we and i've had this
discussion i think paris and they're
like you know at the end of the day we
always recommend for everyone obviously
be yourself you know that's going to be
the truest representation of you that's
what people are going to gravitate to
that's what's unique right and at the
same time like you said you know there
is still a level of professionalism if
you choose to aspire for specific things
if you don't and you want to go all the
way live you want to be loose ratchet
that's cool you know what i'm saying
nobody stopped you but yeah it's funny
if you're trying to get to a specific
goal or like i said you try to work with
specific people then yeah like what
chase was giving you the advice or
pulled you to the side of certain things
you know what i mean and it was up to
you to take it or not you know i'm
saying either either choice isn't wrong
but if when you did take his advice and
you didn't you took your ego out of it
you see how much more opportunities and
stuff kind of opened up for you so i
thought that was dope that you kind of
had that conversation with him and then
the way you've been doing your content
he always been like the big bro
yeah i was gonna say that uh the funny
thing when it comes to something like
that is like you know we had a a
conversation with a friend not gonna
name your names but he he he he made
this this video and he's like yo he's
like you know you know is this too much
and we just was like
all right maybe it is too much maybe a
stock it's like but what do you want
from the industry because that's to
decide if you should post this video or
not
actually you know yeah that's for sure
you you have to
you want people to see you
because when they do see you you want
your best foot forward
you don't want to put i'm i'm just
more skeptical
about you know cursing for no reason you
can be funny without cursing i'm funny
what curses not funny without curses
and
it's just how much you respect your
content you know and that's not for
anybody else you can curse all day
that's your business but i want my
children to watch it
you know so if i'm telling my kids you
can't curse
but they hear me curse right
then i'm giving them a double standard
not saying that they don't hear me curse
outside of this but they also have to
know when you're in the business place
because this is a business
all right
you have to conduct yourself in that
manner
at all times
now
there's other jobs for other people
doing other things right but in our
business here this llc here yeah
we choose
to give you clean content because i want
your drive because we're a long form
podcast you're with your kids in that
car you with granny in that car
you don't have to worry about me
making you look bad right
yeah listen that's real and like the
other day i just want to be clear like
if you choose like i'm not saying like
always the only way this is what we
decided because this is what the goals
we have long term right and it might not
be ever some people are comfortable
getting youtube money or getting it
whatever and that's cool it's nothing
wrong it's just for us we know what
we're trying to strive to and in order
to figure it out we're going to have to
we're going to have to subscribe to
certain things you know i'm saying we
had to have that talk yeah i think he
was going to say something
it really just determines like we were
saying earlier like what do you want to
achieve like you know if you just want
to be a reviewer a lot of those pr
people don't care if you'd be cussing
like that if you want to be you know a
host well like paris was at gamescom
they do care if you're back you're
trying to be like
it says a lot about uh like again it's
crazy you know you think 10 years back
i'm like i wouldn't be talking
yeah you you really and you know some
people they kind of think this is why
i'm so glad i'm out of this space i
still see it now on twitter with certain
individuals
and i got so much love for these people
because i think they could be so much
more bigger yep
one thing i don't make videos on people
because you never know like shout out to
my brother hip hop game i gotta say
hello people disagree with some of his
takes or not saying i got so much love
for that dude when people were laughing
when he was spinning that belt with it
being him and he was being him
you know call
years later yo rick i got something
online and you know i think you fit for
this i really don't know yeah i'm out of
nowhere so he's the realest dude
man look i can i could me him beauty
disagrees
but at the same time it's like yo son
you gotta have love for this because
where he could have been at in his life
you know
but i think people also lessen
themselves because they don't know they
work man they don't understand it i
could curse all day on my stream people
be like are you going to i'll pee up the
podcast i'm like yeah why but i'm like
dude i don't know how to conduct myself
i'm confident that's how
that's the biggest thing uh ricky that
like if i could come on here and not
cuss everyone could come underneath i
don't think adam would have asked me to
be on this show had i been there
that i would be able
and these dudes look at me like no
they're tired
i don't i don't think they ever not
gonna curse yes you understand so it
doesn't have to be a iron lord's podcast
after dark but i have so many i reviewed
these dudes with such high esteem no
doubt i really would do a show with them
and then what's funny is like one of
them every time that we are okay man i
think he's starting to be level headed
no
left we go left like some people you
know we gotta wait there in probation
[Laughter]
gotta protect that brand too you know
yeah
we got
i'm on my platform and i'm like it's in
the game down playing the game that's
all me but if i'm on anybody else's
platform i'm very conscious like i'm not
gonna say this game is trash yeah yeah
like you know i then now i got to get
into details you never know who's
watching that yeah oh boy and i ain't
here to mess up y'all back either you
know y'all got families and stuff so
like right here again yo you gotta love
this stuff man like we have right now
man dude yeah this is great this is dope
one thing i want to get into is i
respect about your content is like one
you always got like the dope music
integration you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah you know what i said that new
york times
i want to salute you on the hustle
spirit like just like
yo your moves you know what i'm saying
the entrepreneurship the business
partnerships you know what i'm saying
like i want you to like to educate the
realm on like you know how someone could
go about making them because you outside
i'm not pocket watcher but you you
making some boys
i see the door there i see the nba out
here i see elgato pulling up what's
going on bro look i see everything y'all
do that's why like me me and addict man
it seems like attic is like that guy
that just gets people around i got
and the big thing that i want just
anybody even myself because i'm always
learning i'm not here to say like oh
look at how you do it so many different
ways but
it's like acquiring all these things
it's
it's fortunate and unfortunate you know
like when you when you live in certain
places or like and i don't like to
always make it seem like i'm some kitty
but it's more like when you put yourself
a certain situation some people they
grow to become the hard workers some
people put in a certain situation
where it's either that or you have no
lights on and it's like i had to work
like you know facebook i'm with facebook
too i'm i'm on a contract with so if i'm
doing 80 hours there i'm trying my best
i'm not perfect i'm trying my best to
upload something on the tube right and
i'm doing 160 hours plus on twitch and
people like you know how you do this and
i'm like if i don't where i eat like
what am i doing
and what there's a difference i love
what i do even if i'm stressed out even
if you're stressed out it's like i love
what i do yes and at some point you know
again when i was doing all that cursing
and rambling and all that other stuff
what was happening i was getting
blacklisted yep i was getting black ball
from certain companies i noticed they
would reach out back out to like my
brother chase but they'll be like but
you know your friend and it's like oh
man they really do watch
just being in that yeah yeah so being in
that space you know with door dashing
and working working and being partnered
with like the 2k league
like you guys got no different from me
we all the same like this
like get the bag but make sure it's
something that really like it's for you
like it's what you do yeah that's that's
bro that's really the thing with me um i
i can't sit here and say that i'm i'm
not proud of my the two my two youtube
channels i really want to go back and um
and take some deep like some long time
and some deep thoughts on some changes
that i would love to make
um
because now that you know fortunately
i've been in a certain position in my
life where if i need to like buy
something here it's like okay cool and i
can make this level of content better so
look again i'm always learning i see how
i duck yourselves and i take that and
look me and chase we haven't done the
podcast but like we watched y'all we're
like but we got to come up with
something like like what they do like
five and it's like man that teeth
talking we just really just love it and
[ __ ] like that's all absolutely
yeah but of course and it's like that's
where it's at so like all this work that
we do
not to go off topic with your question
is like you know
it was just
you have to know you know you have to
know people when you build these great
relationships
it's they didn't just randomly contact
me it's like people you ever downplay
somebody yep from jackson heights in in
new york like and shout out to him his
name is frank
he was a regular dude 3 000 sub channel
people was down playing we met up with
each other at pax i had mad love for the
duke because we could relate have a
conversation years later ambassador for
the nba um
and that's what got me the opportunity
and i'm like
wow like you never know you never know
bro always that's what uh
that's another really good example like
people always want to just reach out to
the top dogs and obviously we try to but
when you can't like get those lower
people man because they they first off
they're never invited to show so when
they are they're excited appreciate it
and then you know we just recently had a
guest i won't name him but you know he
got promoted now he he's above people
and when we got him on he wasn't he
wasn't nowhere near that so it's just
like look like you know show love to
even the smaller people because one day
they might be re they might be leading
that company in a couple of years that
is that is my whole philosophy when we
go to pax
you know um we break down into teams
right and
i call cog the big fish hunter
okay all right you're the big fish
hunter i know how to hit the streets and
scramble yes street teams do you
understand like i i can i can hit
i have no problem with going and giving
out t-shirts cards whatever i don't care
you know there's no pride in when you
climbing up when you're coming from the
mud there's no bottom facts you
understand so you're already on the
floor ground floor so
i let him go do big game hunting they
have the itinerary
i take
one cameraman
which is myself
one interviewer which is either solve
or whoever we got from lordofgaming.net
which you should go to and watch
that
yeah
yeah you know i'm gonna tell you yeah
because kind of better than 19
personally
but
when we get there
i say we gonna hit everybody
we're going to hit every dev
we're going to talk to every last person
because whatever game you got there
i'm going to talk to you about it fast
because what may not you know work for
me is going to work for somebody else
yeah exactly and i'm going to give you
your five minutes of screen time and if
you got 10 games right there well we're
gonna talk about each and every last one
of these games and we're gonna go move
on this is a professional
and when they see you again
the next time they see you again they
like wow
this dude took the time out to talk to
me when i was developing this game yeah
yeah and plus you know it's like i said
like
these smaller people in these lower
positions like it means the world to
them someone reached out to them but
they got to go on a show that they got
to talk to because you got to look like
during e3 during gamescom during tokyo
game show during the the video game
awards all they used to see is their
bosses being on pockets
as being their interviews that's a good
point and i want to jump into because
you know what it reminds me of like two
ricky like what's up when you go to a
packs to me is almost like the developer
is almost the guy with his mixtape that
nobody heard before yeah right so that's
a great analogy with the way you put it
yeah you know what i'm saying like they
like indeed so they sold thirst for
anyone
to listen to and i remember stories
where i'm you know i'm moving up we're
moving and shaking and i got
appointments or whatever and like a
little devil pulled me to the side yo
can you stop a chat and you know really
i don't have the time but i could tell
like it means a lot for someone to just
cover their game you know what i'm
saying so i'm all right you know what
let me just look back around if i got if
i see you i'ma come back
and you end up and you see these type of
situations and then you come back
and then i pass it to solve and saw the
king make a move and then it's like one
of them was like kingdom come
deliverance right yeah and that game
ended up being a monster amazing and to
this day i'm still jealous soft throws
it in my face all the time he has the
number one most viewed interviewing iop
it's not me
and that video to this day
trying to toby shout out to team you
know what i'm saying like
it it took us somewhere because we
stopped and gave someone the time to
cover something you know what i mean and
didn't play your oil you know we ain't
messing with you we only looking for the
big games man
exactly destiny at where is this at you
know i'm saying call of duty whatever
and if we didn't do that these
opportunities don't happen and these
relationships still happen so i agree
good
my most my most reviewed videos on
youtube
a lot of them are from that packs that
the taxes that we go through like by far
like
you know it what's funny is like um
that's why i always there's a company
called um man they already changed their
name they used to be another nd i forgot
all their games man yeah all their games
they they they've they said it to me
like well what do i remember like the
streaming embargo because i'm really
good friends with the the the co
uh the co-founder and he's like and i
was like yo man i hit him up i was like
i kind of want to i just want to find
out when the embargo is like you can
stream it now it's fine i don't care
what's up yeah man hold up shot the pass
he just dropped the jab he's like one
another piece of advice is patience
being told no is just part of the
process absolutely that is true
yeah man that backstory
that video doesn't jump the way it does
also without the support of people that
were already like big fans of that game
i remember to sexy biscuits
they asked us to use the video in a
video for for on their channel and we of
course we let them do it whatever yeah
and they blew up out of that and this
person never heard of them before
and it's it's like it's it's this mutual
relationship that if you have respect
for the person that that that is at your
level or or or you know just starting
out and you're a little bit above them
it you all grow together and that's
that's what i love about pax because at
pax a lot of times like king and i
running up and down the aisles talking
to everybody
and sometimes you don't realize
when there sometimes there are game
makers there that have been in the game
for 30 years made some of the most
classic games you've ever played and now
they're out on their own now they're all
you know they're they're pushing their
own game and they're at the ground level
yet again yet they have all of this
experience and you would never know yeah
i remember i forgot who it was
and
they were showing us the game it was it
was a metroidvania i love metroidvania
games
and then when they're like yeah i worked
on this game i worked on this game i was
a creative leader on this game i'm like
what the hell yeah like
so we could have sat there and had a
conversation about
your entire history and how you came to
this point
and that for me pax will forever be that
place
where if you're a content creator if you
just love games and you want to get a
start
in appreciating everything that games is
from the ground level it's packs
i want to salute real quick
they dropping balls salute to delilah hd
you know i'm saying gwg grown women
gamers she said respect everyone in the
industry as you'd like me to run into
them if you're serious about the crash
you also said be careful about how you
treat people because you'll never know
who i end up being your boss
that's factual that's the fact
yeah she dropped it and you know i'm
glad we didn't talk about this okay
it goes for influencers too you don't
know who's gonna blow it who's not gonna
blow like oh yeah you know treat
everyone respectively because for all
you know
you know
you could have made a good friendship
but it's because they have ten thousand
subs plus like you decided not to do
that
not to even uh decide to try to have
that type of friendship with that person
and then here from that he's got a
hundred thousand subs and he remembers
how you treated it exactly when he was
acting hollywood
that's why i love dylan i love randolph
and jazz
a lot of people a lot of people showed
us love
that was way bigger than that
technically they have no business
business
with 100 subs when they in the
stratosphere right so again it's that
that love back we got to reciprocate
that as well because they gave us a shot
they you know to come on and give us
opportunity it's a big deal gotta pay it
forward pay it forward for sure let me
move on because i know we got we got a
lot of stuff to get into yeah but um i
do want to ask you this i thought this
was interesting first of all shout out
to the sell squad you know say i want a
real quick on that and i want to ask you
about the subscriber i want to ask you
about just like kid you have an affinity
for three letters kos and i don't want
to know what kos was for you so sell
score first and then kos
all right so all right so cell squad is
basically a group of boomers
um
just like for some reason when we game
and we have a great time but
one of us be selling each other out man
every time we play a game one of us does
something that puts us at a loss
[Music]
so we're shooting up threes
[Laughter]
oh my god man you know what guys i'm
gonna call it a night
it's one of those things but even from
from games to conversation yeah you just
you did that like you said that to this
person uh like like again it's just it
came it became that like we was like we
really be selling each other
and then it's like sometimes we sell
snitch by accident
and it's just you know it it's like it
feels like we're right next to each
other we just came up with that name
that name was great
as far as tell people who the sales
squad is oh so
that sound squad is lit yeah all right
so look that's why i got a got a great
group of demographic guys we got ken
which is one of our guys that
we immediately brought him in with the
day we was gaming with him he was one of
our viewers uh he kicked his playstation
the first day he came with us he kicked
it we heard it
all i heard was
that he overheard was
in a bunch of like noise i said what
just happened he said i just broke my
place you know why
i said oh you've been asking us the game
that was nice to be a kid smooth like
the amount of stuff kid smoothie oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh so he was like setting
off a large oh my god so he rage broke
his playstation yeah so he rage broke
his playstation immediately we was
laughing
but like you know again if you got no
chase he'll he's going to laugh oh yeah
he's hilarious and then i follow up
laughing i'm crying and then all of a
sudden you know he never did that again
but just like that energy right there he
was cooling we brought him in but then
we got obviously x chase money whoa yeah
yeah we got high pocket carter i know
from the tv
i've been watching batman's 2k video
yeah for so long super
hilarious talented yes yeah another
another wholesome person who got me many
opportunities he never been selfish
what's up never ever man um we got trey
which was one of my viewers for years
and then all again you just never know
man you just sometimes it takes a little
bit of guidance i'm getting i'm guided
every day when i see new things i'm
learning
one of those he was in college all of a
sudden you know he had his his channel
going on it was a small channel a couple
hundred subs
and just learning and knowing look i see
our formats i'm not gonna take what
y'all do it's called what makes me feel
like i fit in with this lane started
doing it almost at 300k
and his energy you know he knows who he
knows who he is with his content so he's
another and funny and then we got our
young boy raunchy he's my guy man like
he's funny he's the tryhard at every
game
you need them who is a tryhard i'll tell
you right now like we'll all get the
game the same day
and i'd be hesitant to get off
oh yeah i know eddie gotta be that guy
yeah he's the guy
he just pulled me on destiny i said oh
man i i i wouldn't be able to keep up
because i know
what's funny is you're gonna like fire
you're gonna keep blazing yeah when it
comes to destiny i'm the weakest sleeper
no now but you're you serious and you in
your bag we know how you get we give it
dude you said it gems to me raunchy is
that same way raunchy is competitive
raunchy's um
uh how would i say this like we'll get
off the game the next day we're like how
did how did you get to the stage
let me tell you something this is this
is when i know he's an absolute beast
i'm playing dragon quest 11 and um
this dude finished it you finished it in
a week right
i was playing that game for three months
[Laughter]
three months
this dude then after he hits me up he
goes did you get the true ending
[Laughter]
100 on that trade if you don't get the
true ending in dragon quest 11 you
didn't mean
when it comes to multiple endings i'm
always like you get one of them it's
fine but the true ending the dragon
quest is completely different than the
other end like it's a completely
different ending and then you take away
my happiness and i gotta go back yeah
you gotta exactly make you feel away you
know how they go i got ptsd
on youtube for that i go on youtube just
to watch the real ending like dude just
tell me like because now
and that's basically our guys now of
course we got a bunch of guys that just
they be gaming with us but that's been
like our concrete group absolutely and
um again just like you guys you know the
family that y'all built it's like
doesn't matter if we're raging at each
other arguing with each other at a game
we know our limits we know how far we
can go with each other man we say the
crazies of things to each other and it's
like
laughs you just laugh it off man that's
the kind of bond we have yep yeah okay
all right so look
the kos thing this ladder
on the neck bro oh my god all right so
it's gonna it's gonna come off yeah it's
gonna come off like kind of crazy
because
it means kill on site now okay
you name it y'all find it okay cool
what you're talking about
okay cool cool cool so initially the way
it started was when last year i jumped
on twitch i jumped on gta was doing my
rp thing and i formed that group and
that's kind of what kind of pushed my
twitch channel now i stopped playing you
know great the photo because you know
sometimes you get burned out
and i started playing other games but
the reason why what i did with that name
was a lot of the viewers was always like
oh i want to be kos family kos family so
i was like you know what i said let me
switch this over because i don't ever
want a company business and be like come
on fight so
you know and now mama that's how my
mentality right
but now it's like and for the over the
last year i basically take that as
anybody who comes if you know me
anybody who comes to my live streams
with some racism yeah
degrading women because i'm big on women
i'm big on women in the game you coming
here with all that with weird stuff i'm
flaming you i'm getting you the hell
about it you know what i'm saying we're
very close to people from the lgbt
community
people color all kinds of people so if
you're coming to my chat i'm going off
on you perfectly yeah i was so i was so
mad i was so mad that we didn't um go to
uh
uh l.a oh well he's like with the
project
listen listen this was a big surprise
shirt
yeah
[Laughter]
i'm purchasing a bunch of tie-dye tank
tops iop tie-dye tank tops
and i'm handing it out in the parade
yeah
we getting out here are you surprised
because let me tell you something
we are for everyone facts
right everyone
but when they are for you
and they rock with you it's different
they really they're fine that's why we
tell people all the time like at least
for me you know my motto like i don't
care about your politics religion race
ethnicity none of that matters because
the end of the day if you pick up a
controller
we brothers and sisters that's that's it
you know what i'm saying like at the end
of the day we we share this but continue
right interrupt your kids no no of
course no and and what you just what you
guys just said is like and that's why
again i i know not to ever do that on
your platform but if anybody ever you
know
you know comes you know they come at me
different on my stream it's not about me
they just come in the stream and saying
some something that i'm just not talking
i'm going off on you i mean i got my i
got my moments i'll educate you like and
i'll embarrass you i'll embarrass you
and i have to educate you of course but
at the same time you coming in there
with that kind of energy i'm gonna give
it right back that's just who i am i've
gotten very close with developers that
even they were like yo like i ain't
gonna go like you didn't you didn't
fight fire with fire in the sense where
now you made yourself look bad but you
definitely stood up for those who be
like like offended right because i'm the
type i'll be like cyber bullying like
you can really get cyberbully but you
also got to be open-minded and there's
people out there who you know so i try
to we got to be the voice of that you
know like so
i i'm not i'm not taking it from nobody
you come here you speak loyal women you
know i've heard it in the community
people people degraded women for being
main characters in video games yeah
this is ridiculous
but
that's why i love our chat mm-hmm you
know honestly in all respect i love the
chat they can disagree all they want but
they disagree
with facts and and and funny jokes with
each other but before chris hart's in
there every week
you know what i love christopher hart
i don't care what anybody says you know
he yeah so what he don't know where
canada is at
that was bad
man
so what but i love him though
like people don't know like if he's not
in there i look for him
you understand you get to you start
building a rapport with these
individuals i look for these individuals
if something's not going right i'll i'll
text him yo what's up you good you know
i read like i randomly uh added him
inside i don't at nobody
but it was like a tweet for a game or
whatever and i retweeted i put his name
in it because i want everybody to
receive blessings so at no point in time
am i a selfish individual so i really i
really love everybody that's in that
chat because you guys are really the
reason why we are here
right that's okay most definitely yeah
we acknowledge we try to acknowledge
everyone as much as possible we gotta
move on a little bit because i guess
gotta ask the final question we ask all
those in the round lord 3mg
i need those top five video games or
franchises of all time okay number one
this is not because i know you guys oh
you know y'all got y'all be in your xbox
back but halo 2 is probably going to be
my
that was my one of my first like
japanese games rpgs that i played very
early in dreamcast they got it for the
xbox um that was very early
i didn't really play shimu but i played
way the samurai and i felt like way the
samurai generated because of the success
so okay and yakuza as well
oh yeah
is good i got those two i got i got to
do it kingdom hearts like kingdom hearts
that was my seed look at that exactly
he's doing so well now
we're good
explain to you because attic rides for
this and i can tell now why y'all
brothers it makes sense now now it makes
sense so i gotta know
why
it's kingdom head because what again i'm
not trying to be different i gotta know
why you're one of them
i need to know because i see goofy in in
the other and i'll be like okay they
lost me but i need to know why people
are so passionate about the franchise so
one has to do with like i was what like
11 10 11.
and and mind you i was never a final
fantasy guy i was never a final fantasy
guy when i was little like
but then one day i just like i see you
see the game it was used it was used as
something called mickey mouse and goofy
downloaded he was like i'm all the way
live
i'll tell you right now this is how
crazy it was i see i see the cover
because this is at the time you had to
watch like g4 tv
what was going on shout out to g4 tv and
basically it was something called
rockwell comics where i was at in queens
it closed down years ago but i remember
being in there and i seen the cover art
for it and it was between that and crazy
enough it was between that game and nba
street
and ma and remember in the cover you
just had like make you with a hoodie but
you had like this character with a story
and i'm like you know what this looks
different i was playing like dragon ball
z
at the time yeah okay we we got that one
and what made me just like love the game
and again i didn't know any i didn't
even know those guys were from final
fantasy i'm playing it very slow start
but then
just story-wise just started picking up
and i was just like wow music you know
that's what japanese rpgs are like known
for like music and just their themes and
their creativity
and i'm just like exposed to all this
and i'm like but then i see mickey
don't know you know then they played a
role
i'm not lying as crazy
as crazy as it is it came it became one
of those childhood games now don't get
me wrong xenomorph 3 is garbage
look at what they did
i wouldn't say garbage but it was
definitely
i don't know you know what it was
kmart's 2 is still the goat
that game took me like almost a year to
beat i was young and i was slow
i got that okay um i'm forever going to
love mortal kombat oh
the franchise right yeah the franchise
okay franchise as a whole um
i know i know it's probably in a lot of
people's top but like i gotta put modern
warfare too
oh okay
okay that's that's one of the goals
yeah my first thought was paul duty four
but on my one for two was when i really
like on the 360 and the ps2 was like i
met so many people yeah even though
playstation's voice chat was lagging we
all lagged together you know
shout out shout out to the batman shout
out to them extra spicy lobbies
where you know after the post match when
that talk was going down ricky we know
what it was you had to be built for you
had to be cut from a certain cloth
rules you took it you didn't know how to
hit your mama jokes dude i had to go
there i love the racism some of my best
friends
the biggest races and you know what i
don't i don't know mate
i guess they said later on i got a black
friend i got a black friend from the uh
they know
let's let's keep this real true racist
they ain't telling other people
like you got to that point like no this
is my friend this is my friend king
david yeah
you guys are like why you gotta
man if you wanted that accent i just had
my brother coming here
shout out to zach
the way he said friend was wow but
anyway
and the last one is good like i have
this so many games but the last one i
gotta what's up
oh
we gonna get into it too yeah yeah
you kind of look like cradles yeah
everyone say he black cradles yeah
yeah well
it's black
and my eyes are black
it's a cake
david i'm gonna tell you right now i am
not lying if you ask green mason ask
them online to go there and be like king
diamond
yes time or pig with the racist friends
of call of duty oh anyway
last what our favorite console of all
time and why
favorite console of all time
whoa
it's stuck because
well i would honestly have to say the
ps2
ps2 the ps2 and it's not it's not even
on something like all sony and that you
know it's like ps2
that's some of the biggest library of
games oh
biggest and
i was it was from def jam
rhymes and again these aren't these
aren't exclusive titles these were just
games that i played on that platform it
was uh
madden i think oh six i don't remember
playing a lot of these games nba live at
the time was going crazy
it was going hard in the paint with that
console that console went hard in the
paint yeah i would have to put the ps2
and then i'll put the 360 right after
that and then
i don't even know what else i'll put it
no no no there's just one
one
you gotta pick your favorite kids your
favorite kids the ps2 everybody else's
favorite kid you know absolutely that's
my favorite kid
that's right
with tremendous gaming history you know
stories powerful love what you doing man
we got we got a lot more to get into if
you got tired to hang out with the
homies you got some topics let's get it
oh let's get it right he's about to get
spikes about to get spicy you know what
i'm saying but you know it's funny my my
friend's been messing with you this
whole time he's uh especially when you
said kingdom hearts and then he messaged
me and he said he said why are you he's
like do they know you're a playstation
hater and i called it i said
y'all was like i was like you might want
to go ahead and like like turn off the
stream right now
i'm
it's gonna be spicy but look you gotta
get the poll real quick last week poll
results are in the people have spoken
with the recent reveal of halo
infinite's release date at gamescom open
tonight live do you have an issue with
it not being revealed on xbox game on
gamecon stage the winner at 36 of the
vote almost a complete three-way tie
was the messy lords i don't care all i
know is this halo anniversary better
line up with bungie's 30th anniversary
to give me the halo destiny crossover we
deserve
coming in at second
and tied for last place because again
this is a two-way tie for the last two
which was yes microsoft should value
their biggest ip by revealing it on
their own stage and b no the gay halo
deserves the biggest stage for all
gamers to get the information regardless
of platform so the second one is that's
the correct that's the crowd
before we get into it we got a legend
that just pulled up in the realm we got
it
xbox expansion plan close to 100
episodes one of the best audio xbox
podcasts out there except the ghost man
talk to the people man how you feeling
brother gentlemen hello everybody hear
me my audio good yes
album let's go
man let me tell y'all something i can't
tell you how good it feels to be back
here in the realm with the lords meeting
ricky for the first time i was listening
to y'all
earlier
uh about bringing people along the way
you know reaching out and helping out
people and that helped out you and
someone's playing hades
i am see i'm in the middle of a run
i'm not
i'm not stopping but no i just
appreciate y'all but uh let me be here
you guys are amazing
uh yeah man episode 99 drops at six
o'clock eastern tonight oh bro a big
honeymoon good to see you brother like
we got a lot of we got to get it to the
top so we yeah as saab says y'all know
what we're here for yeah let's get
before before we get to that let's just
get this super quick there's a couple
ways we got we got kiss move five
dollars in the chat sup iop and three mg
brother blessings
then we got sin vendetta once again 10
super chat man all this system link talk
reminds me how me and my friends all
bought four og xboxes with halo combat
evolved and system linked through a
brick wall into four separate rooms
oh gee i'm liking this
then we got a bundle 10 super chat
this is so y'all forget how i treated
y'all in the past
yeah i don't remember
though coming out it was like yeah he
used to yeah he used to i mean
welcome brother you know it's all good
it's all good though the bag gonna have
to be a little bigger though
[Music]
let's get to it so look you know what
we're here for
playstation 5 oh god okay
a lot of information a lot of
impressions so we got to get into a lot
of stuff showing so obviously people in
this chat is not going to like me today
everyone's got their disclaimer but
we're going to get into it get get heart
get real quick yeah i'll get rid of that
target i need 10 super chat the show so
the sony show made it clear that we
don't need a ps5 by the time any ps5
only games come ps5 pro will be out
wow 2023 not cool sony we believe in
generations more like we believe in mid
generation
will you read that name one more time
for me
oh my god hey
oh [ __ ] let me get big class shout out
to big clown gaming files from chat my
brother
moving up love to see it salute to you
all your salute to you man i love seeing
you get them playstation
brother you moving out here you're
moving right brother i like how you're
moving so look let's get into it so i
feel like this is going to get spicy
get ready it's what they've been waiting
for
so let's get into it man let's start
with you love 3mg obviously i i saw your
stream you obviously i saw some
reactions you know what i'm saying
so let's get into as a whole what was
your thoughts of the show highs lows if
any and your impressions yeah showcase
okay so one
for me like being that again i i get on
i don't care i'll get on sony when they
they didn't appear at e3 they didn't
really announce that much this year it
was like where were you um return was
cool but return on for me i was like all
right that's one game but where the
games that y'all was talking about so to
be honest
it was like just like that intro you
know i seen the intro they had like the
chess being played and everything but
you know you got to be i me i'm excited
for it it was like it was the end of the
uh at that little short like one
45-minute conference that they had a
game show uh showcase
it was like that's kind of where i seen
their moves i thought they were coming
in with some cool games in the beginning
um especially the um i think it's called
code v
that looked really good i think uh
square enix for spoken i don't think
that's an exclusive but regardless that
game i was waiting on on that game the
game looks good it looks good
um then they had hit us with some games
that i was just like okay what's this
all you talking about that game where
you get better uh pet crab
crab cats
something it was just like all right
come on man you guys
dude i wasn't i wasn't with it i was
like yo come on man like and we was all
you i don't know if you've seen the
reaction it was all like dried out
if you saw my reaction i was going nuts
he was excited are you you're going
because he crowded
oh i told people what it was
it's a multi-player
and
i feel about this but i'm i'm happy that
halo's coming to pc i love you know what
i'm saying i love it
so i was happy who i'm in the pc
what do you mean what who did that face
maximum really is spencer did that for
you sir that's why he did that
and i'm happy he did that thank you why
i love the cross play i'm
i'm past that old style you know what
i'm saying so seeing that on top i beat
uncharted but it's on pc now i'm a
little bit of a graphics
the whole gym dance moves ryan he's
complicit that that game going over
there that's a boss move
no no no i'm talking about i know and
i'm talking about uh them taking that uh
that that uncharted over there to the pc
that's the best glad they did no no i'm
glad they did
he's all about playstation games going
to pc now that that acquisition
i knew where they was at
man i know and you know what listen man
they take toes down in the dirty
the best pc parties this side of the
mississippi and they are working i can't
i can't be saying that i ain't gonna lie
dude all i know
it benefits us because like while people
getting mad i'm hyped i'm like yo this
thing is coming to pc
why are they getting mad don't they got
powerful pcs
no no no no not pcs
no but i'm talking about the playstation
dudes don't they got powerful pcs to
play
[Music]
you know what's crazy
is that
i wish i would go against what you said
i laugh at the same thing i feel like
it's funny when you see it like when you
see people make these like statements or
they just sound ridiculous i'm just like
i'm like i'm gonna play horizon on my pc
yeah now you could play native
why would you kid to play
whether if it's the series x or the ps5
i don't care hey they cause they can
preach 8k all they want right they ain't
going to get that ak like oh fast
[Laughter]
[Applause]
tcl does have the first 8k tv out there
but is it really ak though it's like
this is i'm not going to be like
until somebody can actually hook it up
and get some content on it we don't know
like we really don't know
it's good
they got 8k on the box for the
playstation they still can't do 120
hertz i mean come on now let's be
ridiculous you're ridiculous continue
3mg with your assessment of the show and
what's so crazy is like i can't even
stay here dude i just turned on my
playstation yeah the first time last
week but i can also get it called
the xbox
that's because of the access that we
have now like yeah
i can i could get game pass on my pc and
just run it all like yeah
i can and honestly i'm happy that a lot
of playstation games coming to pc it's
just like the experience becomes broader
for me i'm cool you know just dude
[Laughter]
i'm going to tell you right now that's
going to be the most influential
developer to deal with i gotta go front
you know i was going
a playstation controller move into a pc
box
because
i'm unaware of like this nexus thing
like you got to put me on
there
they never got to get the name right
first give me the presents
yeah so pretty much this was remember
what you know i've seen a lot of the
game companies are in the studio
acquisition phase and
at the time you know obviously you know
xbox have made a lot of acquisitions so
when it was time for playstation
obviously they reside in zombie act
which was you know they locked them in
beautiful and then one of the
announcements was uh when was dixis and
what it was is king would order red
talking about that they don't realize
the deciding that they're hyping is the
playstation fanboys ultimate devise
because what they don't want generally
some hardcore playstation families do
not like their games on pc and he said
this is literally the jim rohn he's a
fan of jim ryan though
right now because
jim dance moves around his moves he
putting james brown to shame the way he
move his feet to the side
anyway
back on play with with dmg
so i'll mention the game overall i mean
um
you know what maybe because of the
developing studios that announced their
games i got super hyped for like if you
would have showed me
horizon forbidden west again autumn like
dude you showed us this like four times
we all been waiting for god of war i've
been waiting for that trailer
and insomniac they're really holding it
down right now like just like let's be
honest they're holding it down right now
for playstation announcements get up we
always we got to be like we got to be
conscious of like those are some of the
best cgi trailers i saw yeah yo listen
but yo but king they come anything on
the box yeah thank you listen listen
that's real yeah but i mean for like you
said
how is he wiggling this way out of this
one
this is crazy this is crazy so you turn
your playstation on and it calls
i'm still alive
which you both had in the box i know
that's how you avoid that he said he had
both consoles in the box but he's but
he's playing xbox games on his pc he got
a powerful piece
listen he got a powerful pc for a reason
so you can play xbox games it's
beautiful um but again and now thanks to
nexus
your playstation 2. but i'm saying
now that you you know brought it out and
then you're gonna play def loop that
will be on game pass because you you
know you take it out i'm definitely
gonna play the a yeah yeah definitely
fine fantastic we endorsed that over
here um
at the same time it's gonna go right
back in the box and then
we'll see you next year with horizon
coming up
and it's crazy man
so you know it's not uh just so like i
don't hold y'all off so insomniac
announced
wolverine and spiderman too bro i heard
your spider-man reaction bro i watched
your video bro because because man like
just like batman like those two
superhero games is really holding it
down on the streets like i think they
hold the standard for superhero games it
ain't even about the com at this point
me and gmg like we kind of like we
understand why exclusives exist yes but
at the same time we gotten older enough
to where we're like man just why you
know but we understand the business side
of things oh yeah but like on a real
real non-trolling standpoint y'all man
for us we and bring us all on pc now you
know that
i really was happy to see that
wolverines being made
and spiderman two was being made and
just again i said 2025 is gonna be oh my
crazy no no no no but both you mean
because we ain't gonna see like hey
don't get me wrong though i mean i'm
biased i mean halo's getting ready to
drop halo infinite on bias because that
that's forever like oh
my god then you got four
but i'm also i got my biases with like
certain games i'll play this there's
always going to be a bias here but in
conversation i got to say like
more man like we we we spending money
with both sides on their games no no
check it out you know when you go on
game pass and you know how it is like i
just was telling you i was playing awful
escape for no reason just for no reason
just to download it and eat that right
cookies
right so
my playstation is still dormant until
they hit with that banger so when that
bangers show up
mine's going to jump over that
i'm going to throw it in there but game
pass will keep rocking until they drop
they did have ratcheted clay and return
on this oh yes they did but i'm not
paying a 70 price tag i'm not paying
attention
like i'm not doing that
you're giving me likes generations
and you want me to take seven dollars
this is my theme i think by the end of
this conversation you're going to
realize like hey now you could tell me
that's going to sway me into this
i'll put it like this man let's go look
i'm somebody who subscribes to both yes
talk to him um
when did uh xbox come out when did
playstation 4 come out like 2013 i
believe like yeah end of the year right
right and within our dark days that's
when we got down to the leadership
remember that yeah
i mean regardless but at the end like
from that point forward it's been eight
years
roughly so we got rough stuff and it was
it was man like let's be honest like and
another thing too i love game pass game
pass absolutely it's an incredible
service i also like to be like
you gotta be
yes we were getting beat to the floor
uh-huh
as no ricky was saying there was still
eight dark years
guess what it affected and it looked it
was a dark decade
it affected me too because i'm somebody
who subscribes to that library i love
that
where it's at and one thing i'm gonna
say which again if you disagree disagree
but i think i think personally
i you you they can't like what what
happened when it was what see these
cuphead
um halo gears tactics it was during that
time and it's like yo we you know you
put those games so high up there but
there were so many delays delays delays
right true it like it's upsetting for
any of us sitting here that's like yo
man we're attacked but we got to keep
ourselves conducted but like at the end
of the day i'm a gamer brother you don't
know where the game's at i'm complaining
playstation playstation at the same time
doesn't really have multiplayer games
right i'm just like i'm on my
multi-class now right since but people
think like you know i heard this
argument recently they're like oh the
playstation only got single player dude
they've been having only single-player
games since the 90s
i don't know where this became a thing
so that's the art form and you got to
respect them for their art form i've
always listen i troll a lot like
you already know that you know i troll a
lot but i also purchase a lot so when
they do drop what i want i'm gonna get
it that's that's just you know pure
facts my question to you king yes sir
are you gonna wait for that spider-man 2
to come together hell no
like you really think you really think
the second i can download that at twelve
o'clock midnight or the second day put
it up in the store you win i'm dead in
there that's my game that's that's all
it's about
while people like you know i see it on
twitter people complaining and people
making the most craziest things you
mentioned
you said something about
the god of war animation in the boat
yeah they go a little bit they'd be
watching dude
let me be honest that's like complaining
that why do guns reload the same kind
and i'm just like what is it like when
was that halo does the i love halo but
we're not going to act like halo was
they don't i mean i guess the recent
ones they have like a little bit of
sprinting but what made halo halo gears
is the same thing they run like they're
heavy they're gonna really complain that
they do that like and that kind of
conversation i'm just like oh man you
can't have a conversation
with that guy exactly right i agree with
you on the animation like when i saw
that i was like okay you know he has a
point but it's like is it really this
like is it that serious like well it's
like
but they they don't have a point though
they don't have a point because it's a
staple
built on the same engine yeah and i get
that but but when you play another game
you do expect you know at least
different ways
let me finish one little thing let me
finish before you guys start jumping
down my throat
i did say it's like look like at the end
of the day like
something like that is so
like minor that i don't understand why
people are talking
it's not that it's even minor it's weird
to me because they're talking about
craig we're going to talk about that
boat
we're going to get that boat we're going
to get that
man like and i found it to be like
confusing because i'm like wait a minute
so like i played dishonored when the
second one came out
he's still
releasing abilities the same way and
it's like you're right and let me tell
you why you write about that just like
just what you said
that joint was built on the same
hardware the same in the same hardware
as people and let me tell you something
i'm gonna give you an even better fact
that dlc that they're gonna pay eighty
dollars for
they're not dropping dlc on that oh
he said he said you went too far right
too far he's looking no he's looking for
the synthetic
you see what you're dealing with yo rick
at the end of the statement you're gonna
be like oh my god this is true
and you went to the table right
and you saw asgard there
right yeah
you thought at some point in that game
you was gonna get there right
yes
yeah
yeah yeah
okay he's like i know where this is
but you can't get there but
in that trailer
we gonna go to asgard
[Laughter]
you implying this is an extended version
of god of war yo they
they put it there they told you what
we're about to do to you you're gonna
see it all right can't touch it now
we're gonna see you in 2023. we're gonna
see you in 2023 we're going to see in
2020 i don't know if i picked the right
week or the wrong weekend
there's a game that we want to sit here
and complain about i would complain
about last of us too
but i don't even want to get there
because i think it might it might like
no i love that game you know i love that
game that's not mine because for certain
reasons yeah you know but i would say
this
remember uh
remember halo 5 guardians yeah mm-hmm
remember when i was running all damn day
in that game and fighting and then at
the very end i thought i was going to do
something but the game ended yeah
the way it ended it said see you next
year
and it's like oh we forgot to tell you
on the last episode of dragon ball z but
that ain't going to come out today
let me ask me this
what's up is it on the same engine
oh we're going to use the same thing i
can i can honestly say
no i i don't really i don't
i i've been like so i don't i look for
y'all okay so all right so let me
explain yeah
we got to get the ghost in
your ips is high i'm sorry but me and me
having a good time so right it's on the
slipstream engine right that's a whole
new face engine you mean yes let's space
slip stream whatever the hell
say the name all right listen that's why
i got you there to correct me what's on
slipstream um the halo infinite infinite
okay okay okay not halo 5. no halo
infinite so you're not going to be
seeing reused assets
you ain't going to see the same boat
animation yeah you're going to see the
same the same thing that you saw over
here but
i don't i don't want to take anything
away from the game because when i saw
and i told people before the
i'm a show but i'm a real troll because
at the end of the day i told these dudes
what can save the show for me
god of war can save the show for me
what i saw i was pleased with because at
the same time i knew that it was going
to be played on my playstation 4 pro
so
why are anybody upset with what they saw
they gave you what they said they was
going to give you and it's going to be
played on the older system you can't get
a playstation 5 exclusive game that's
not feasible in this time with the
economic things that they're going
through so i i love the game
all right so let me now i have to tap in
and unfortunately as much as i don't
want to agree with you i have to agree
with you so look i'm gonna put it like
this
i i don't understand why
so many guys because i'm a fanboy of a
lot of things you know i'm proud to say
like yo and i'm very conscious of things
i mess with i don't know why i went on
twitter and i said wait dude like
playstation dudes were complaining
about the reveals and i'm like what if
they announced spider-man first and then
wolverine in the middle and then gotta
work in with you i've been happy i'm
really confused because so he wasn't
announcing anything sony wasn't making
no news they were quiet so i'm like and
you know that kind of hinders a lot of
people who do gaming podcasts sometimes
because like those dedicated only one
console podcast because i'm just like yo
dude you got nothing to talk about
there's only one drop in the news and at
that point we don't
me and my guys we don't sit back and say
oh yeah but sony's still the greatest we
sent him back like yo man i want to turn
it on
what's going on that's the way i'm on
yeah so
but i'm really like i can't even sit
here and even
the animation dude when you get into the
boat i can't like that's
my concern is more so like
all right wasn't the release date yes
yes
2023 good point 23 i'm not even 100 like
i don't know i think forbidden west is
coming out next year right in
in february and i'm like in that game
that game went into amazing supposedly
in march
i love grand theft auto and i love forza
gran turismo kind of disappointed me
with the last one because they were
promoting things that had nothing to do
with racing on their front game like
watches and perfume like what is this
ain't even racing culture and then you
got to make money so again forza took
over
can i jump in on this one
i want to talk about the animation thing
real quick first
real talk if there's any game in this in
this past generation that i'm okay with
reusing assets it's god of war bar none
i don't know how anyone can be upset
that you're getting more god of war i
don't care if it's god of war 1.5
i don't i mean if it's the miles morales
argument it's a small expansion i don't
care like that is the exact game that
i'm pumped for for real and playstation
credit where do and critique where do
they drop two exclusive games the
beginning of this year xbox is dropping
two with the back half of the year
xbox is doing forza a racing game and a
big first party game at the end of this
year that's exactly what playstation's
doing at the start of next year right
and this tit for tat is exactly what i
want from these two heavy hitters
because they have playstation did
nothing different than they've done in
almost every showcase for the last 10
years sell you on the future that's way
far out yeah make sure that you don't
sell your console that's exactly right
that is exactly what they do
they put hope in the box and hope that
you don't walk down the game stop
themselves
i agree with that and um
but it's like yeah and i don't even i
don't want it to be where it seems like
every time something is said i gotta say
something about xbox i want to say
something about both because i'm not a
nintendo guy
i love nintendo since i was you know i
put respect where it says nintendo's
always yeah
they only dropped their own game so of
course they're going to always sell the
most this is their own games but at the
same time we've seen a shift
where both consoles the dev teams
just couldn't fully commit to dropping
games on time and i don't know
being the reason yeah last year we've
seen games dropping and i just want to
say cyberpunk is one of the worst games
that they that was
until they drop that um
it don't exist for me like that game
that you remember the gentleman was like
hey i beat the game i ran through
certain bugs a year later we get this
and i'm like what did you beat yeah
i think what yeah what we're going to
say at it i think to me like when it
comes to the animation stuff it's like
look like
it'd be different if the other god of
war
was like
not
on par but to me like got a war visually
animation wise it was ahead of its time
back then so it's just like you mean the
2018 version yeah yeah so now i'm
feeling like all it's doing is it's just
you know making that a little bit more
equal because it could it's been a
couple years to me like that has aged
well so we don't need to complain about
that you know what i'm saying like like
and i understand where key's coming from
the point because
the game
the game well i mean we're talking about
like the dlc stuff if you do if you do
see it
no you know
and look i got the perfect perfect game
to compare about being ahead of his time
when i seen when i first played forza
motorsport on the 360.
graphically
for that machine because now that you
know as we you know years later we look
back at certain games
forza still was like a beautiful looking
game on the 360.
and
right now as we see forza dropping
i'm there's obviously upgrades the game
looks gorgeous but we can't i can't sit
here and say that the draft is like
drastic changes because that studio knew
how to master
that game through its console
generations while every game was
struggling to get 1080p on the og on on
the xbox one that game still managed to
visually look like beautiful yeah now
with god of war 2018
i i the game graphically still looks the
same like it looks the same for the ps5
and the ps4 it looks the same but i have
to now say same thing with turn 10 i got
to say santa monica
you know they mastered how to make that
game look so good now it's not an excuse
to say that it could have made it look
better right we don't even know
spec wise if that game is going to do 4k
once we don't know any of that yeah so
based off that one animation like look
remember the last three god awards i
mean an ascension if y'all want to count
that one they had the same layout for
years right same animations you know you
just acquired different things from
different greek gods but in this case we
got to see what's going to happen i
think that and even if it was somebody
doing that with halo i would get at them
too like really you're going to complain
about the animation with like halo like
halos remember the fruit yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
i lie i look at this stuff and i'm like
damn i would have entertained that
argument
the game show
as disappointed as i've been
with um because xbox uh recent show when
they show like you know them acquiring
bethesda which that's a that's a w move
and i don't know why people are
complaining because sony also acquired
studios like that's what you're supposed
to do right um
i they show some heat and i said dang
like but i do believe on both console
sides we're not going to really see the
potential of this kind of these two
consoles yeah like the next two years
man it's because of the way they
releasing them that's not that's not
fair i think i would have i want to get
the goal set again just i know you
jumped in but i need to get your
impressions of the the showcase what was
your standouts and overall you know how
did you feel as a whole with the
showcase except it goes yeah
yeah yeah um
i felt like it was a decent show like
honest to goodness but it was a decent
show in a very different way than like
xbox's e3 showcase yes uh the highs of
the playstation show were very high for
me yeah the idea that that venom and
miles morales and peter are all in the
same game
like that as a superhero fan it's like
how can i not turn my playstation 5
on or whatever you know what i'm saying
like i gotta get it give it the cough
and get it up there and then
same thing
when you see a game like wolverine which
we saw it literally says no actual
gameplay
there are three studios on this planet
that i had trust completely with
whatever property they're working with
that's rocksteady that's respawn
that's insomniac
zombiac has put put banger after banger
out there
all right you're making wolverine i
don't want any big third party property
to be first party exclusive and locked
by a console whatever gotta get a
playstation if you don't have one
so the the highs of this show were very
high for me um you gotta credit sony in
snagging two previously first part two
previously exclusive xbox games oh okay
we talk about that goal alan wake up
talk about that ghosts
let's let let go
where do you want me on this one i want
you now historically
where did this game debut
mm-hmm which i mean you got kotor that
that debuted on the ogx box and
it debuted at a time where bioware was
doing their best work people widely
regard this game as one of the best star
wars stories of all time
and how many people missed it right a
lot right a lot now goes you asked me i
answered this how is it that this game
is an xbox exclusive right that's that
debuted on the xbox how is this
exclusive to playstation i'm telling you
right now if xbox and microsoft need to
learn one lesson from sony it's make
those deals cut that check
make those deals
i don't do it for rise of tomb raider
that was never going to be what you
wanted it to be right but make those
deals because playstation has shown that
they will go out and they will spend the
money to bring those third parties in
and microsoft
uh has got a lot of w's on their card
over the last three years especially the
last two
but if they've got any ls it comes from
the fact that they will not cut that
check and make those deals to make that
happen i date that girl over again
i don't care i don't care if you put
lipstick on her
i don't care if you put in a brand new
dress and which console are you talking
about which female is this
there's some red flags when it comes to
kotor remake aspermedia is known for
ports not remakes
so that's a concern
right maybe there's something maybe
there's something there i'm sorry
footage of the game sure didn't and i'm
i'm worried about it because i don't
have a lot of trust in ask for
immediately
but i'm kind of curious like the
narrator who was talking there maybe
that was um that had been mystique i had
probably butchered her name there i it's
just i don't know like that's the one
thing that i'm not a hundred percent
with right now um i'm very excited for
it because i'm a huge quarter fan but
it's just like if that would have been a
studio like bioware remaking their own
game i'd have been a little bit more
hyped for that no bioware no obsidian
there that's a worry and then when it
comes to alan wake that we we knew that
was going to happen right we knew alan
wake was yeah
i just want to ask you one question yes
please sir if you're going to pick up
the new range rover you know kia made it
mm-hmm oh stop we're not doing that we
just got a point not doing this
that you know and what's funny is when
it comes to my turn king ain't gonna
like me at
all this one
i can agree uh it is like look we can't
be 100 hype for a studio that has no
like no past thing on making these type
of games
this should be such a beloved franchise
xbox has every damn rpg
under the sun exclusive under no what
i'm saying is this they sh a long time
ago
they should have gone to bioware and
said we want this game
with mass effect why why is this small
third party team
the one that's making this game out here
looking like trey songz out here mr
steal your girl let me address some
friends
let me address saul you're 100
right and microsoft should have done
that but you know what else why didn't
sony go to bioware
can i yeah let me let me let me let me
comment on that
do it on the cheat
okay so
answer your own question why do you
think someone can go to bible because
obviously it's owned by ea but to my
point is look at bioware if sony would
have went to bioware they're like yo
remake this will pay for all the funding
we want it exclusive i would have been
hyped but sony didn't go to them
i don't even know for all we know sony
has nothing to do who chose this game
they just came in towards the middle of
the negotiations like okay we know
you're making this game we're talking
about what you wanted here's the bag
thank you yeah but to me it's like
oh
it's like the thing that happened with
with the with playground making fable
like look i'm excited for fable
but at the same time i'm like they've
only made racing games i gotta see proof
that they can make a fable game same
thing here i'm not saying the studio
can't make this game but i'm looking at
them with a magnifying glass because
this is automatic
no no if no if microsoft would have did
the same thing i would have did it it's
like look like this is a very important
brand to me and i'm not liking the fact
that a studio that let's be real no one
on this panel knew until this game get
in your defensive
strongest i'll give you that making such
a an iconic it's equivalent to the 2018
god war coming out having someone else
make it instead of the people
step back step back from that good i
mean sorry it opened the playstation
showcase
what i want to talk about
but no one is saying that no one's
trying to downplay that all i'm saying
is it opened it that's cool but at the
end of the day
we still gotta consider oh my god yes it
comes out we still got to consider who
was making it that doesn't matter
hold on i got i got to jump in with this
what did you like
i just wanted to hold on
because
yeah i don't even you mind if i let him
go first then yeah yeah yeah
well i think we're arguing about two
different things yeah the quality of the
game is is up for debate lots of red
flags okay go back to that point ask for
media the fact that the question was at
the very beginning
you know how did playstation get this
get these two games alan wake and kotor
which are historically xbox king makes a
good point it's been there before but
king i'd push back on that and say it's
been 10 years for alan wake 20 for kotor
and alan wake has ties to modern stuff
we knew remedy was going to do it i
think it's a miss
on microsoft's part to not let people
identify alan wake and control as xbox
games exactly right
i think that's a myth
for kotor red flags all day on who's
making it
but it's but playstation they they power
move they cut those deals and they got
those previously xbox games
in their showcase yo keep any any game
not it's not about whether we like it or
not is that the people identified
correct as an xbox or playstation game
and then they went and swiped it now
xbox has done this too yeah xbox has
done this too the names escaped me at
the moment but they've gone and swiped a
few i mean ammo be the show in game fast
this is one of those great examples
and i'm happy that mlb the show's on
there and i'm glad that there's cross
play and i'm glad that um
and i'm hoping that microsoft sony does
more of that because
with longevity um i'm gonna be honest
with you like look i'm a big halo fan
but we're not gonna act like when master
chief election dropped it
and ran poorly and said a lot of us in
the community absolutely and even to
this day thank god that there's cross
play because
the i was playing with a lot of the same
guys same thing with gears you know same
thing with gears but i'm happy that
cross play exists but this with that
with that game it's definitely
concerning because when i heard that
playground games was making fable
immediately immediately i'm like i know
they got talent right but you also got a
you're playing cards here with with guys
like is the writers gonna be different
obviously
yeah can i say something yeah we all
said the same thing
about raising your hands
we all said the same thing about
guerrilla games sit back and let them
smoke
um
and you know they have a pedigree my
question is the pedigree of this company
that's nice to know
and this and this that game comes out in
october right
which case i wasn't sure if i was you
know allen wayne from republic right now
i don't i don't wake his october 5th
yeah it's a remaster though it's not
it's not a thorough thing so republican
no day no date he didn't mean to have a
date we didn't have a date for that all
right so we just got lucky and that's a
remake like that's a remake
it's a real quick real quick ricky
what's funny is they advertise that like
final fantasy 7 advertise theirs final
fantasy 7 remake core tour remake
and
here's the thing here's the kicker
though like all i got from you know i
bought every xbox that released uh for
last gen whether it was the s yeah the
xbox one x like multiply and honestly
i've gotten disappointments from both
that and the ps4 pro ps4 pro is one of
the worst consoles made um it sounds
like a jet engine i felt like i was in a
g6 every day
i don't like it
that matters yeah exactly and just even
even alone spending that much money
knowing that's gonna probably break soon
because that that that console was
terrible but um
all in all like yeah it's concerning you
know when it wasn't rock steady who made
origins on batman origins and it was
like another i think their b team all
these things become concerning i was
hyped at first when i'm like hearing wow
it's coming back i played this game
years ago right but then when you start
hearing who's the developers or who's
like
behind it it's the same thing with
certain cod games that we're being
developed oh yeah that's a fact
and it's like those are always going to
be concerning factors i know the hype
came in when we see who's initially
releasing the game we're like wow this
game is going to come out but i'm i
can't it's so crazy i remember i used to
be like xbox ain't this xbox ain't this
and now i have to say both because at
the same on the on the same spectrum
it's like
microsoft was showing us nothing but cgi
it was showing us thank you you know it
was showcasing nothing but cgi at some
point but of course we get geeked and
i'm like yo but when is it coming out
and then we hear you know um what's that
one game made by platinum
hillbound we can't sit here
i knew he was going to say that okay
i saw it at the show so every time
somebody says oh scalebound i really
wanted it it shoulda came out no you
were just hoping for the l to hit us in
the face
[Music]
all right so do you know why he'll walk
past that huh you know i feel well
pastor cause it was garbage nah man i'm
asking do you know why phil walked past
it because it was garbage
i mean
that's the inside
i know
baby oh tell me so pretty much platinum
games got caught up they're making
multiple games at once they got a whole
studio though spencer's like wait what's
this other studio that's going on and
pretty much it it actually makes him
look bad because he's as he's pushing
out all these other games recore and all
these other games you know you got a
developing company that they trying to
make exclusive which was scalebound
which would have been a great addition
because i think what xbox needs yeah the
university is is to try to get that
demographic over there because xbox was
holding it down for years with their
with their with their competitiveness
that's what brought people together with
that with that console right and not
having scalebound release that was one
thing but seeing why was like wow so
y'all was trying to double dip on
multiple titles and yeah i kept pushing
that game back when they found out that
deal right bam he just broke ties with
him now who knows i think he owns the ip
still right yeah they still own
flagships
yeah man get that out man
get that ip to somebody get it out but
also microsoft that got money yeah yeah
i ditched it out to try to make your
xbox like a cable box at one point or
drm and all these other things you got
money you got bethesda man you acquired
a big a big a big studio with bethesda
and i'm not gonna lie
i think def loop is probably in ghost
tokyo i think it's called yeah i think
those are probably gonna be the last two
games he's gonna touch playstation
because the playstation because the rest
is coming to xbox but microsoft needs to
start
start actually getting towards like
these other businesses
yeah yeah okay so we're gonna get to
that i know you're going i know where
you go okay okay okay i just want to get
the um scores to finish his overall
score yeah
and then we're going to get back into
the what the competition should be doing
but i got you bro i got you no doubt
overall score on the playstation yeah
i mean seven it was not a bad show but
it was a it was made good for me by the
highs
and the lows i walked away from like i
was just i was like
what was your lows ghost
uh
shoot some of those names i can't i
don't even know like after project eve
there was somewhere like it sounded like
japanese pop music i heard
even as somebody who
who admittedly plays a lot of the
avengers mediocre game that i love yeah
um
i couldn't care less about guardians
okay but but when i see insomniac
yeah when i see insomniac and spider-man
insomniac and wolverine and then god of
war yeah how can i be how i got three
incredible games on the way at some
point in my future okay fair enough you
know rick
your score i forgot to get your score
before i passed the attic
three of three your score oh my score
yeah what footage i would i would say a
seven out of ten
okay yeah okay all right
that was fair enough lord addict you
said you've got things to talk about
they're not gonna be happy with
yeah look okay
first off i'm i'm going to say right now
the show was a good show i didn't think
uh i can't i'm always for the little guy
so to me
giving these people the stage on a
playstation show i can't front sony for
giving people on that level of stage on
their show
uh
but i will say that you know there was a
lot of stuff when they didn't appeal to
me right but i can't front man like
microsoft's got a huge issue right now
that's
that is appealing to the wider audience
and i feel like
they do have a lot they have the elder
scrolls franchise we're not going to
downplay that that's a huge franchise we
haven't seen it since 2011 but
when that does show up especially with
the popularity of something like elder
scrolls online people are going to look
at that right but
there's something that's bigger than
that franchise that's called the mcu
and to me if you want to appeal to as
many people as possible you need those
house
hold names
the wolverines the spidermans the
ironmans like you don't have none of
that microsoft it to me
this was about showing to the average
consumer
we got these games coming right we got
this spider-man coming we got this
this this wolverine coming look and to
me if microsoft doesn't respond with
their own household name which i i know
why they're not doing it and obviously
maybe they'll change their mind after
last night but after a couple days ago
but to me it's like look like
they want to build their own blocks
they're tired of messing with other
blocks they get torn down because they
don't want to make their blocks anymore
right
and i think it's a little bit different
with sony because sony has
such
a close relationship with disney because
they keep fighting with them over the
spider-man movie license and i
personally feel like they're probably
using that to their advantage too yeah
get the wolverines to get the spidermans
oh you want this this spiderman for the
mcu all right we'll negotiate the money
but we want to make a wolverine game on
top of the spider-man game right to me
can i jump on something real quick there
yeah attic i apologize for interrupting
but i did i like the disney analogy
there
i will point out that microsoft
in their own category indiana jones and
then the pirates of the caribbean and
see a thieves tie they don't have a john
drake making people shake hands between
disney and sony but there are
relationships between microsoft and sony
otherwise i'd be like oh dude
yeah yeah you know like we gotta do
something and they gotta cut a deal
somewhere wb's a mess right now i don't
think batman but like yo the matrix
that's got a trailer coming out can we
get a neo in here like right ghost i
think the biggest issue they have now is
they need to get a studio to make these
guys let me i'm sorry i was going to ask
you one quick question because i see
some
the the counter our argument to be fair
because you know that [ __ ] has to be
fair you know everybody hates that but
um but kind of will say well you know we
don't know one what microsoft is cooking
and then they say well you know why do
they have to imitate sony right like
what do you what do you say to that
it's not about imitating sony's about
being competitive
if sony's constantly going out there
getting these household names like
wolverine and spiderman and microsoft's
not doing the same which you know they
are getting uh you know indiana jones
but even phil spencer said we're gonna
we're going to honor
previous
engagements so we don't know if that's
even going to be an exclusive question
uh you know there's a good chance it's
going to be but until that comes out and
the information's out there we gotta
it's up in the air 50 50. to me even
indiana jones doesn't even
hold a candle to spiderman doesn't i
and it's like look like i get it people
you know they they want microsoft to do
their own thing but at the same time
you've got to compete to a certain point
right and at the same time well one last
question you're on fire my question to
you is what in your eye what would
competing be do they need
to compete in the superhero space and
have something or just something of pop
culture that's popular that they have
exclusive like what do you feel is
competing i think that it wouldn't
matter as long as they had something
that's very popular in a household name
but to me when it comes to like because
obviously other forms of media it
matters how you can transfer them over
to this form of media and i think comic
books are one of the easiest realms to
do that we can think of
but then it comes who's going to do it
who are they going to hire a second
party studio to to make this and there's
that chance that they have with rice in
a row where they continue they don't
want to make that in four or five years
so it's to me there's a lot more things
that's going on here and and it's just
like i said like it's about con
competing competing with sony they don't
have to make exactly what they and you
know i was talking to cow over at tick
network and he's like i don't want the
making a shooter marvel and i'm like
look i get that but at the end of the
day like to me if you want to do
something but you want to do it that
more as a pill to your studios
i don't have a problem if coalition
makes uh makes a punisher game makes it
gory makes it m rated it's just to me
you need to have these conversations
because if you it i honestly feel like
microsoft's thing right now is like we
want to build the elder scrolls up we
want to build the outer world
and that could be huge that that could
work out for them it can they could
easily not go anywhere near the comic
book realm and if these games hit the
way they say they're going to hit
they'll be fine but at the end of the
day
it's about getting newer people
and what is going to get newer people
into the ecosystem is it an elder
scrolls sixth where we ain't seen one
since 2011 or is it or is that a
punisher is it you know things that
people are seeing on the screen right
now black panthers black panthers
who are we trying to get to the xbox
ecosystem it's the fortnight people it's
not the elder scrolls talk to a woman is
at the end of the day
those people they're going to buy the
game regardless because their fans are
ready
i want to piggyback off that because uh
i'm gonna be honest with anybody who
would disagree like even in the chat too
like i'm reading the chat and i'm just
like man like so i want to i would just
say this like
is it necessary that microsoft competes
yeah i don't want to i don't want sony
to be the only console like i don't
nobody wants that i don't want it to be
where then they have control over
something no kid wants anything once
they're destroyed
um he wants microphones
let me add something real what i want
let me add something real quick look
when it comes to you know cognito is
always on that just one it's like how
about we do both of them for two two
birds with one stone give us a punisher
third person action adventure very high
quality game and then you you you appeal
to the sony crown and you get that
household name out there at the same
time
i'll get you good to you
what i want um
is utter annihilation
i want to assimilate them like the bulge
i want i want to get out to the star
track references
yeah i i want i want god of war on xbox
i want like mlb to show his dick don't
sit there and tell me that ain't never
gonna happen son because i can go to my
xbox right now and that sony logo pop-up
and i think i'm gonna be the show which
is a first party game from sony and i
told you dudes what was going to happen
y'all looked at me it was like king and
never shut up give me your knees
this is at the point right now they're
the precipice guys
y'all sitting here talking about oh yeah
there ain't no playstation 6 coming oh
and you guys are sitting here talking
about that the wolverine the wolverine
the wolverine will come when the cloud
playstation 6.
it's still coming and it's exclusive oh
they listen
we don't know that oh bro
it's coming by them but you asked me
what i wanted for them this is my wants
i want them assimilated i don't want to
ever have to go pick up another console
i want my one console and i love them as
a developer because they make beautiful
i love the single play experience that's
like just one right you're not gonna get
that man but you know what somebody told
me i would not play the best baseball
game in the world
different kings that's different and let
me tell you this time out
when phil looked over because i saw it
in his eyes he looked over because
because you know cog went over to him
and said like yo how come we don't got a
baseball factual
i said this to phil spencer's face
[Music]
he looked at you was like you know it's
just technicalities in there but you
know what you did you sparked the idea
in his head
you know when you spot that idea in his
head there's other people sparking ideas
in his head i'm sparking an idea in his
head so your ideas are simulating by
them destroy them
you're not going to destroy them that
mob the show has done better than it
ever did oh yeah because it went most
exactly and that's what the mlb is so
many the mlb was telling us you could
put the sony name on it but we want this
to actually range from more and that and
i think that's what like people don't
understand i want sony to destroy xbox
just like i want xbox to destroy sony
in a competitive nature
i know it's necessary i'm gonna tell you
the truth we can't keep going every
console that drops and think of only
those three games gears forza and halo
we can't keep doing that that's why they
said
can you repeat that's part of the
hashtag just one movement
you just signed up to my movement they
purchased 27 studios to stop that new
year but
you can't like this this is why and when
people say oh but sony don't have a
shooter i'm like yo you're going to make
that argument all you want and guess
what's happening they're still selling
units because of those reasons like
they're yeah it's almost they're
obtained it's almost like going
somewhere you could have the freshest
outfit but if i got something designer
on people gonna look at me first sony's
over here getting getting exclusive
games from insomniac and it's like
dude i've spoken to phil spencer before
i went to e3 and he was there the dude
loves god of war oh dude loves all those
things
okay
let's point out too let me jump on
because
if if you know that you're going to get
those exclusives you're going to get
that console and then you're going to
play your third parties for the to fill
the gaps your shooters your whatnot
destiny is available on both you know
what i'm saying cod's available on both
that's what tends to happen you flip
that
and you look across across the aisle if
you want that multiplayer experience
with your friends you got sea of thieves
you got halo you got gears but those
single player narratives that you're
talking about cog
at best we know about hellblade and we
don't know anything about him and
remember how blade is a sequel it's not
a new ip
you're right from someone else was it
was it not creating a new ip in nigeria
that's all i'm saying right okay you're
right yes
they're doing it on both sides so like
you know iron hellblade i was hyped i
was like oh yeah i'm going to go
there you go you gotta do it and i think
what bill spencer also needs on his side
is honestly like i don't know how
budgeting works here i'm not good with
that stuff i don't know how those how
that works but somehow someway
um you notice sony separated themselves
too in terms of how they're gonna name
it they call it playstation studios you
know like you know i don't know if
that's because of other back end things
but at the same time microsoft i want
them to take these risks these these
necessary risks right you know you need
to look at what companies out there that
can make a crazy story driven game and
try to go after something that's big
because again it's not about what you
want to play it's about making sure that
that ecosystem doesn't die out we need
that yeah
so all right
all right because it turned into
something different
but again but but but again
everything you have to play in your own
lane to stand out just like every
youtuber
has to play in his own lane to stand out
right so when you go to copy you go do
mr me too it don't really work out for
you that way it don't work out
you got to build your foundation first
right now let's not act like microsoft
wasn't wrecked up with what don did of
course don took us to the brink like
literally it was almost no xbox right
all right so we the reason why his name
is phil dominus maximus are really
expensive is because he took us back
from darkness and took us
so at no point
it's been
but by that argument if it's not
overnight and you have to build up your
own ip and get to that point where you
have more than the three that just like
playstation does with playstation every
single time they drop a first party game
that character their main character
whatever that can be their mascot yes
at that time at that time you can't say
the same thing for xbox who's the new
protagonist for the series x generation
who who oh there's nothing right i mean
i don't think protagonist is who
is the platform right for the platform
right
to how sony does it right like like
everybody's been saying before sony
knows how to make a splash
and the splash in it of itself is enough
to drive the narrative that they're just
better
right
it's enough microsoft
and i i appreciate game pass and i
appreciate them trying to build up their
own ip and have that stable the problem
is it doesn't make any sense if you want
to be perceived as the number one
you have to beat the number one at their
own game not consistent i don't believe
that that's it no no see that's it
that's what sony did to microsoft you
have to you have to at least show that
you can do it well no i agree like being
able to be able to show that you can you
know make a game of that caliber and
that quality is different than beating
them though yeah like i feel like if
you're putting out good games in that
quality okay they haven't even done that
there yet but they haven't done it let
me just let me just haven't done it
saab is exactly right because in every
other category microsoft has gone from
worst to first services hardware
uh
building up with acquisitions supporting
developers indie relations they've done
it all but he is absolutely right better
deals you have got to beat them at their
own game to dethrone
we're not saying
that the entire xbox game studio
template has to follow sony correct
exactly no no no we're saying right all
we're saying is out of the 23 right
you can say you are in making in
development one game of that ilk still
continue doing all the amazing things
that you're doing you're doing that you
listen they got the best value the best
you don't want to argue like we're going
to say power but services smart
everything they're doing from a hardware
and services standpoint it's fire it's
just this one thing achilles heel and
the other one that we don't talk about
is fighting games fighting games are
garbage they don't have no they're not
even in the space let's keep it going
what i'm saying is just enter the space
that's the thing it can't say you know
how you know how easy it is that we talk
about game pass is great all the artful
escape all these hot games the moment
insomniac wolverine over look over we
get into these arguments all the time i
don't think it's ever gonna change like
to me
like you know i'm talking more about
like a mainstream media thing like to me
they are making those type of games it's
just they're not brand new ips they're
making the hell blades they're making
compulsions making one gears is a
third-person action adventure like like
to me they are making these games but i
do agree with they need new ip ones like
i guess
real question because like
from what you said just just before
about beating them at their own game and
everything
that's exactly what happened not not
only because don matrick had contributed
to that madness which of course he did
especially with drm and you having to
download this the game all that stuff
was bad for xbox we know that
uh playstation had a lot of bad with the
ps3 you know there was barely much it
was harder to develop games and somehow
some way
as and remember that game had hdmi they
were the one and at the time the 360
when originally came out didn't have
hdmi they were still using uh
but they were still dominant they were
dominant why they had the space of
bringing people to gauge together they
had competitive gaming they had the
voice chat system everything was
seamless you didn't have to pay xbox
live chat there was so you could be
playing one game i could play another
game all these things that they've had
right
what really carried xbox let's be honest
when when halo 2's and all those games
and gears right the multi-players carry
and that's always going to be the
end-all be-all with both consoles the
fight of course when the ps4 came out
listen
we've seen a shift and it's not just
because
matrices
and i'm gonna of don
hold on playstation
all of a sudden at
beating microsoft at their own game
microsoft was a juggernaut juggernaut
like they had the call of duty okay so
first first let him finish no i'm just
gonna tell him one thing because what
he's doing right now is okay let's
separate microsoft from xbox at that
period of time it was just xbox okay
okay okay okay
okay all right so with xbox regardless
of the console right
both and deals that were being made
right sony and
to
come to come to this idea and this plan
how whatever was the decisions that was
made in the back end they acquired
tournaments to be played on 2k now
exclusivity with the 2k league call of
duty we're not going to act like
exclusively
yes what was carrying the xbox 360. we
can't say gears and halo 3
it was cod
when they finally acquired that we seen
a shift of gamers everybody left so what
i'm saying now is microsoft needs to and
they should and it's like because again
we we not we may not play those games
right because
thank you
okay so thank you this is where you 100
right at right and and and i'm not going
to tell you that there wasn't worse
there was a huge no no no no no no
there's a it's always going to be a butt
it's a mouth of course no i don't know
of course all right so it's always going
to be a but but at the same time
microsoft at at that point and and you
completely they fumble the whole ball
when you don't have the backing of your
higher-ups and stuff like this this is
the this is what happens when the wrong
people are in charge right if you don't
care about your job you're going to do a
poor job
right but then you can have the same
person in the same position that
actually cares about his job and he's
going to do a cellular job
so they had the wrong person in the
wrong position
and what he did was catastrophic
so at that point in time we are facing
the brick i don't care what nobody said
it was almost no absolutely xbox
absolutely right so now
all the stuff that was done in the dark
yeah you have to build yourself back up
you lost call of duty that's a huge loss
all right especially when you only get
the now they lost call of duty and then
they lost destiny coming out the gate
listen you got burger fries and shake
your burger fries and shake is halo
gears enforcer correct you can't keep
serving people burger fries and shake
and think you about to win the game fact
i'm glad you said that because i've been
on many podcasts where people just don't
say it and then you know like and then
you can have that conversation with them
because they won't they won't understand
it's like you can have the conversation
with me because i understand exactly
what playstation did to get in that
space but this is the distinct
difference
playstation is a major earner for sony
yeah
so sony looks at playstation as this is
our cash cow factory and we're going to
back them 100 1000 did microsoft look at
xbox as they cash
when i spoke from when i spoke to phil
when i first met him yeah along with
other creators
um this isn't like something that's
personal it was more so like they were
given a lot of like money at first but a
lot of ips and you know how that you you
guys know just like i do you talk to
developers y'all know how games come out
what's being funded for these games
and there were many
misses
you know i'm gonna be honest
as excited as i was for a lot of those
games on the xbox brain it's unfortunate
that people ridiculed like feel for it
and they you know but he's taking that
position so even if there's things going
on in the background oh yeah he's gonna
get hit with it you know and he's got to
take that but i still believe that he
done he's trying to do it like oh
that's right
yeah i don't i don't want people know
like thinking this is like uh you know
yeah this is
yeah the conversation
is what could they do to improve other
areas right it's okay so this is what
happened
microsoft actually
looks over at xbox as the same way sony
looks over correct at playstation
the change happens now right
and and y'all want that one just one and
i feel you i hear everything that you're
saying right i'm not saying that you're
wrong right i do want to tune into a
show and they're saying that this
single-player narrative experience and
the the highest quality from our best
studio right is coming to you this new
ip and you won't get that at these shows
though
that's something we need that's
something we need in la and i'll just
say this last point is
i think a lot of times too people and i
and i only recognize this because again
it's not about the sony community or the
playstation community a lot of the xbox
fans and originally was ps2 fans you
know and then they jumped on that oh
yeah
it was it was always being shifts so
for one i'll say a lot of playstation
users were always used to those
single-player experiences right
and
one thing to note
is
when with microsoft
yes you need those experiences but also
there's a lot of people in that
community that i've that i've learned to
like become friends with yeah a lot of
them were talking that talk man but they
weren't out here buying and supporting
some of those oh yeah king exposes that
all the time you know all right cool
i don't like that cause i'm just like yo
man yeah like some some people within
who are who who go extreme with yeah
yeah i'm like i check your trophies
they're not playing the games
like who knows the potential sales of
tomb raider could have been and square
enix would have just been like yo let's
do some more deals right let's get some
more stuff with you now i'm gonna tell
you right now squeenix is about to
fumble the bag with marvel avengers in
that galley um guardians of the galaxy
because the way insomniac is looking
about putting that out is looking crazy
but i want i want the next big halo and
somebody in your chat said it earlier
they said there's no character that can
compete with master chief well there's a
problem of relevancy here that's the
chief is always forever going to be a
relevant stable home stable character if
you play video games right we're not
going to act like kratos isn't it it's
not mainstream though yeah no no no no
but master chief i ain't gonna lie i
think he is
i think he is
i do i agree with you but there's a
difference between like mainstream on on
family members of gamers and gamers the
mainstream of just people going to watch
movies people going down walmart of
course what that will change you got you
got no i'm sorry
i'm just be quick kratos is a household
name for gamers just like master chief
is they're both going to hold they both
hold a very important part spider-man
the household name of everybody yes
that's that's right that's about to say
that
that's where i'm going
and that's where xbox gamers have to
understand
at the end of the day
we understand as gamers you said it
beautifully master chief kratos right as
gamers the gamer community know but you
throw spider-man and wolverine you get
somebody's mom you get somebody's cousin
you get somebody's grandma some of the
old guys the old guys
they can even play video games to now
look at gaming because of what addict is
saying a pop culture ip and microsoft
has zero huge differences that's all i'm
saying all i'm saying is they are
spending money they've turned around
king is right they have spending money
they've turned no one's this is not doom
and gloom xbox all we're saying is jess
in that space for whatever reason right
they're just choosing not to compete in
this specific space and all i'm saying
is this is showing right that sony could
have a show
they could just announce this title
and the whole world is going crazy look
right
because
background can happen background you see
all those characters
microsoft needs to buy one of them thank
you
let me ask you guys a question like
because i think
well just spider-man i don't think this
was an issue right but the moment that
wolverine was announced then it's an
issue because now they've made a
one-and-done thing to a pattern
and now everyone's seeing this this
marvel universe being built and they're
like there's not on microsoft yeah
there's two on experts
what are they now people was like what's
next that microsoft's net getting that
playstation's getting what are the
chances that wolverine and spider-man
are not in the same way you stole my
thought
very low very low i want to speak to
ghosts real quick because to me
it could get spooky on this level
if they happen to decide to say yo we
want to make a video game marvel
cinematic universe
with insomniac when all the characters
go back and forth in this game and you
got the quality of an insomniac with a
great narrative team and let's just say
miles morales and spider-man happen to
pop through on a level on wolverine
that's crazy that's exactly what's going
to happen [ __ ] that's exactly the
shadows there's a marvel verse being
created by insomniac there's references
to the in that that little trailer there
it's absolutely happening though and i
want to point out
that
it's happening because it's been botched
in other places the multi-plat avengers
game yeah didn't do what it needed to do
insomniacs did so they're my if i'm
marvel i'm saying well i got a proven
commodity that's gonna sell out the
wazoo i'm gonna at the very least make
make money over here in this exclusive
space microsoft needs to don't hit oh
come on no no no no no no no no hold on
i gotta answer and if it don't yeah it's
gonna disappoint let me go it's gonna be
upsetting it's gonna be sad to see that
hey they developed the game like this
and they didn't but they tried
yeah like if we're hyped we see the cgi
i'm like oh snap now if i see that cgi
trailer and i see within the next year
or so 15 more release trailers of that
game i'm gonna be pissed like yo when's
the release date but if it comes down
25.
probably probably
probably four or five but that's the
same but that same with them so you said
it i said the same thing when they first
announced halo a few years ago i'm like
alright cool when next year that next
you know i didn't come out now look like
you're playing with my emotions now man
yeah so and if that wolverine does not
hit that's gonna that's gonna suck
because like we see with spider-man
how well they did it like i didn't think
this insomniac was gonna be able to get
another ip and marvel event was supposed
to be the destiny of marvel right like
with the way and they didn't carry
themselves so
last point and i know i'm going extra
hard on
this is the part i have to i give
kingness
and i'll pass it to him after i'm
finished because i've talked enough the
thing is this um
i think what's happening here my guess
is that
historically
superhero games have not done well
if you're in that board rule right
before that and they're still nice
i mean look look what's happening now
correct still not doing it yeah it's
only sony games
the way i look at it to me there is no
reason with microsoft oh yeah money
and everything that they can't snatch up
whatever they want to snatch up right so
to me this is in my opinion the business
the boardroom saying you know what
[Music]
dumb joints don't always bring a return
right
it just to me what's happened is
with insomniac sony has caught lightning
in the bottle
they have a trusted studio like ghost is
saying that is making quality superhero
games that marvel themselves even trust
and sees that return
right and i think that's what's
happening because to me
you can't tell me that sony's
outmaneuvering microsoft in the
boardroom with finances if it comes to
buying like this
we know microsoft you know so it has to
be a con in my opinion a concerted
decision to say you know what we could
do that but let's look at you know the
guys pull up the number crunch bubble
double yo but you saw what avengers did
this you saw when that wolverine game
back in the day did that you saw what
all the failed spider-man's did that
right and someone is saying
we'll let them have that space kind of
thing and it all i'm saying is it it
would to me it would be like i said like
some cataclysmic mistake i just want
them to say hey let's take a chance we
see
let's say trust the studio that we trust
first right right that has the category
we trust the studio has to be first that
when you don't have one go buy
rocksteady there you go there you go get
the studio first and then when you feel
confident in that studio to do it
get one just get one that's all i'm
trying to say you don't wanna hold on
i'm sorry i'm really sorry to cut you
off not only just that what you just
said yeah please but there's so many
writers in the industry that left
studios that are goaded right so like if
you get a writer like for insomniac they
went from ratchet and clank they dropped
and then they did sunset overdrive right
and then you you go ahead and drop
spider-man just like guerrilla games
i've never really been a fan of you know
i can't kill zone i've never really been
a big fan of killzone that that game
felt like i weighed 500 pounds
and then i spoke to them one time i ate
they're saying so what's the next thing
and they were like we have an ip we
can't announce but sony gave us the
green light they are finally allowing us
after 10 years of of being a part of a
franchise they're finally allowing us to
make a game we want right they actually
said that to me you know um then they
closed girl against cambridge
unfortunately absolutely but there but
their main studio the guerrilla games i
was like okay all of a sudden you go and
i was skeptical yeah i was like you're
making this game but you came from this
and look at what happened i want to see
microsoft make it it's you know that
microsoft has yeah those games that they
invested in like the records or maybe
like the tomb raiders or the dead rising
right but i still think there's still
time like to invest in those in those
like like it's like box office number of
movies
they've been doing that with studios
they just gave initiative perfect dark
but if they're going to poach a writer
out there i don't know if you guys know
him by name evan narcisse yes yes this
is the man did you go you back a dump
truck of money up to you say
write us a blank story whether it's
about invincible or black panther who
he's familiar with that's where he got a
lot of his fame sure and that'd be a
perfect character for him but like yo go
up to a well-known writer and say write
your story we'll find you the studio
that you want and need for this
yeah you know that would be the way to
do it right there
real quick before king goes
you know how big of an issue this is for
microsoft disney retweeted this sam
thing really like
disney retweeted spider-man 2.
so like to me
but i i i get that but there's a
difference between like a little dlc
coming to see these and and see it's see
these are doing well i can't take that
from them i would consider that their
flagship of last gen even though i
didn't like that game but the fact is
disney is telling people yo if you want
to play spider-man you got to get a ps5
yeah
yeah anyway i mean okay
look final on this man it's just for me
those two things aren't mutually
exclusive i love that my microsoft is
growing they're stable i can't wait for
the day when i can look at sudden one be
like that's a xbox mascot yes i can't
wait for the day when compulsions
character is an xbox match i can't wait
for that right i can't
baby whatever it is like whatever the
next wave of characters are i can't wait
for that but those two things aren't
mutually exclusive and and if you give
the masses a game like that with pop
culture
sort of bravado you're gonna bring them
in and then they're going to stay yeah
they're going to stay for the for the
ones that really matter to that
ecosystem create a new fan you do how
you do so i i hope they do it i hope
they do it at some point but for me real
quick
um so i wasn't there on the live show so
i wasn't reacting with you guys so
the thing that i from the beginning i
thought i thought they were gonna bring
smoke like smoke smoke smoke smoke
because yeah as corny as that opening
sort of video was with the chest playing
or whatever it felt like it was a like
like they were they were you know they
were throwing like smoke like listen
the king is here
we're here to drop something and so as
corny as it was i was like okay let's
see and then
when they drop kotor first i'm just like
damn they're really coming for it like
this is this is an ip that never whiffed
a playstation and all of a sudden it's
theirs now for whatever extended period
of time and the thing is
a lot of times people will throw out oh
it's a year
i have not seen
an a hair of final fantasy vii remake
still covered yeah it's so covered i'm
still i mean it's easily easy to assume
that these things are a year or more
right sony has been shown to be petty
and extend and extend and extend so who
knows if we don't see this game on an
xbox platform for two years so
in my mind at that point it is an
exclusive like i'm not you know in two
years yes if i haven't touched the game
i want to play it right it's like put
out with destiny right at that point
devalues it because it's two years
you're getting i hate exclusive dlc
though i'm not a fan of that
even if it came out for playstation yeah
but look i'll lastly say this and we
could we want to whatever else i would
say
if anybody here
if if xbox was to like if say
spiderman was exclusive to xbox i think
xbox users would be having that same
energy too and that's what i want that
what i want is
to acquire something because at the end
of the day even if i don't play those
specific games
the last thing anybody wants
is to have something where
you know and i'm glad not glad what
happened to microsoft that they went
that they pummeled a lot because i'm not
happy about that but i'm glad then all
of a sudden the game passed they started
releasing it for cheap prices for a lot
of people to tap in yeah but but why
they're doing that because they're like
oh man we need to come up with a
different game plan
all i ask for is like
is those i hope they're not suffering
from what ea suffers from i know people
from the back end they they're right now
um they're suffering the fun nba live
because they don't see
going up against 2k and they're not
getting the funds for it
and i hope microsoft doesn't see that
like get the writers and and look at
what's mainstreaming right now and see
if you can acquire those licenses
there's no way disney's going to say no
right for you to drop a game one day
disney would want all games being made
by the right devs
they're going to make money back too so
yeah that's what i'm hoping for
yeah so um in terms of the show i think
the pacing was great right i think the
pacing was great i'm not a big fan of
the the playstation like interstitials
between stuff it doesn't make like when
they when they were revealing the
console that was cool because at the end
you saw the console but the transition
yeah i don't know i don't care just go
to the next game um i don't think they
did themselves any favors by separating
out the third parties from the first
party yeah i agree because it really you
can see the disparity in a way that if
you mix it up at least in the moment you
don't see the disparity there um from
the third party stuff again uh before
spoken is probably an exclusive for a
decent amount of time i think that
looked great
um ghost wire is probably a year
um everything also i didn't want to see
death loop again definitely on tuesday
i'm good i don't need to see it anymore
um
project eve project eve
it was pretty
but it really to me the fighting games
made that for a second
right it was in it and it just feels
like that sort of typical even like xbox
360 generation sort of japanese action
game they all sort of feel and look the
same and i wasn't excited by it i'm like
okay it's another one of these yeah you
know we have bayonetta we have um devil
may cry so you know we have um
what's going to call it uh
near automata something yeah whatever
like maybe it's good whatever but it
doesn't really do much for me oh
all the stuff in the third party stuff
like again i'll play a lot of that stuff
but it wasn't super exciting for me i
wanted to see what they were bringing
down the pipeline so once we jump into
uncharted you know hey i knew that was
happening at some point yeah we're
bringing those uncharted games to pc is
happening
um the big stuff for me obviously was
was wolverine to see wolverine um i just
my thing is how many people are working
at insomniac because insomniac has to
have 500 i mean is that the point can we
we can make the argument now right they
are okay they're the number one i mean
we know nobody dog as far as the quality
you can still say right brought up a
naughty dog is going to give you who did
your game's a generation who did the
trailer for
wolverine
i'm assuming this isn't something yeah
this is on there oh they farmed it out
to somebody to be put together they
farmed it out
give me a cgi trailer for this game that
we're going to do later
they don't need a billion devs i mean a
billion workers to put up oh no i'm just
saying they're making their game they're
making spider-man they're working hard
they're putting sony on their back it is
fantastic i think people are
y'all caught up in the moment
nah dude
bro these guys have been working since
god
god bless you this is ratchet and clank
2016. god bless right god bless you they
dropped spiderman right drop miles
morales right they drop rift apart they
deserve to be purchased
there
and remember what they purchased them
for 200 million dollars like a
ridiculously low amount of money
whatever their workflow is it is the
most efficient workflow in gaming right
100 percent in addition to that that
studio is bigger than we think it is
there's no way there's no way they're
all just working on this one game and
then jump to the next you drop
spider-man and you drop dlc
ratchet and clank
whatever the case is the formula is
still the same upgrades the graphics all
right put this little thing here put
this
so what's the point you're trying to
make
i was just getting to after you finish
i'm gonna give you my predict my show
okay what what i saw with the show so
are you saying that they don't deserve
necessarily the prophecy no they are
they are right now they are holding sony
on their back i'm not disputing 100
percent oh yeah
everybody said they're getting up at the
moment we're not allowed to be hyper all
right no no
um you don't get a chance to eat a
terrible meal
and then be happy for the dessert
all right
yeah that's all i'm talking about
but you don't know how happy i am about
the meal
we have done long format on this one
topic yes that that people walk it went
from this area to that area to this area
where you guys got to what this
the conversations came from what they
showed right
so
so okay obviously wolverine i'm excited
for whenever that comes out gran turismo
i'm kind of with 3mg there like for me
gran turismo has not been the same for a
long time i you know and for me forza
has taken that spot i'm not even a big
sim guy like that so when i think about
a racing game i'm thinking about horizon
i'm thinking about other things um
gran turismo looks beautiful
we'll see if it does come out in march
like they say it's going to come out we
will see or whenever it's supposed to
come out um spider-man 2 look great
obviously anybody who played the first
one knows the whole venom stuff uh and
cravings to hear craving the hunter is
exciting
um
god of war
so god of war
and this is a my bad type of thing is
i guess i expected more
for whatever reason
everything that i saw i'm like yes more
god of war great
four years on hey
i
when i finished the game in 2018 i'm
like okay
i love more god of war right now
four years removed i'm like more god of
war in kind of exactly the same vein it
was a little underwhelming i'm gonna
play it i think it's gonna be a super i
think it's gonna be a huge game because
there isn't gonna be a trilogy this is
the end of the whole norse sort of
timeline
so basically they're going to egypt next
like this is like he announced that i'm
thinking this is going to be okay
yeah he said like this we're going to
end the story here of of like norse like
of the norse mythology so
to me that means this is a last of us
two size game
um in terms of you know 30 to 35 hours
worth of gameplay
i'm excited for it
god of war in a lot of ways was was
amazing i loved the combat everything
about it it was again it was i think my
expectations were different than what i
saw right it still looked great looks so
polished but i wasn't wow i was weirdly
i was surprised that i was underwhelmed
okay yeah all right so i give them this
i give them six and a half to seven oh
wow okay yeah all right no doubt king
you've been waiting patient let's get to
it score the whole bit
well yeah they got a five um
jesus they got a five i'm keeping the
same energy with those cgi stuff anybody
else
i'm keeping the same energy with the cgi
stuff all right
so um all right i want to add something
real quick what to your statements kane
do you think like you know bring this up
sometime in what you're saying do you
think that maybe sony's getting a little
comfortable with the milk shake and
fries like because they are showing a
lot of exclusives on you know sequels oh
no i know shake your eyes how to do
about releasing the same games over and
over
they're kind of doing that now what what
what yeah okay they're in sequel city
they are in yeah
he already told jim dansman ryan's
already said that he's going to double
down on the aaa titles the big titles um
so that's no surprise none of this stuff
is a surprise them opening up the show
with a bunch of multiplats in the
beginning and a chessboard game trailer
i sat there and you are not supposed to
on yo on your d-day
you're not supposed to have me running
around in my room laughing at you
do not and don't ever forget it go back
and watch it i laughed at you for 45
minutes
and you showed up for the last 10
minutes and was like shut up king you
don't get to say shut up king you don't
get to say shut up king for something i
said they better have this here to save
the show
they showed god a wall
then they showed cgi trailer
cgi trailer
and here we go king we good
no we not good
we are not good
now god of war i was happy with what i
saw
because i knew that dlc was coming at
some point in time
and i knew it was going to look the same
exact way that it did i see people all
upset they don't look next gen king it
don't look
it's on the same engine this is peaceful
using the same assets
if you think the turnaround was going to
be uh how long did you stop acting like
you don't know how long games take to
make
so yes i'm very happy for a new god of
war
i'm more happy for spider-man but i had
to take off points because of the cgi
trailer
that's the only thing i only took away
points for the cgi stuff and i say the
same thing with microsoft you come with
that cgi stuff i'm going to get you you
do you say this
with that yeah i don't care for that
yeah i wasted no time showing me
something that's not representative of
what i'm going to get
don't do that for me
don't don't don't show me something and
then debate and switch later on and oh
and then they go back and sort of
downgrade
all right so
we gonna keep the same energy
when microsoft showed a bunch of
multiplex
everybody was like oh my god what are
they doing that's over there that's over
there that's over there
of that stuff interests me when i watch
a sony show i watch with my money my
wallet what i'm going to buy
gran turismo looks very tempting
it does and if it does come out before
forza the next motorsports game i think
i might be buying gran turismo
to just get my sim game in right it
looks that good don't don't don't please
don't front like it don't look that good
it dude
god of war i'm gonna buy it spider-man
i'm gonna buy it damn you know look at
my room i'm gonna get wolverine when it
come out
so at no point that's an eight right
there right but then i have to minus out
for them cgi's one point for each of
those
so that brings it down to a five because
none of those multiplex i'm buying from
them that's hot i'm not doing it fair
enough all right so if you're telling me
to spend 70 80 on your games it got to
be something i'm going to open my wallet
for the games that i'm opening my wallet
for you held it for the last 10 minutes
of the show attic said it perfectly if
somebody's watching this show
they left early on and heard about the
announcements later
so it didn't hit if you had a fly in
your soup at your restaurant you're
sending it back to the kitchen and you
out of there i'm not paying for this
it's a roach in my food
if that happens for free i might eat it
depending on my finances
we've all been there three years we've
all been there
but anyway it's just listen
i see people they happy sony did
something at the end of the show because
if they would have just showed that god
of war and walked out the door
i would have been upset
and walked out the door
these dudes these dudes
i do feel
i do feel like without wolverine we
wouldn't be having this conversation
like it would be really bad
that's all i'm saying is just people are
acting like they didn't see the same
thing i saw and i and i'm not saying
that those multi-plats don't look good
i'm not saying that
but when we go into a sony show right
when microsoft do it oh they got
multiplex why they showing multiplats
why are they doing why y'all showing
multiplex acting like that oh you see
you see so now i'm starting to
understand you more because
yeah
you know what i do look at what i do see
i'm starting to understand you more you
see
you've allowed
that side
to get to you so that's why you're very
strong opinionated yes yes well you're
not wrong because
when look listen you remind me a lot
like chase once we see a trail in this
cgi it ain't gonna look like that though
yeah
there's a point to be made here i'm on
that same type of time my excitement
wasn't just you know it wasn't because i
was excited that wow
finally i've been asking for x-men
legends game for you i don't care what
platform it would be
but i will say
i was kind of mad that ultimate alliance
came out on the switch
i'm still furious oh i'm with you bro
why i'm with you i want the petition i
want them to come at detention.org
but my thing is yeah no like see town
i'm excited for spider-man i'm hyped for
wolverine because of the idea that it's
coming from a studio that i trust
because had ubisoft announced it i
wouldn't even be talking right now
before did you release nothing but um
from all far cry games even though far
cry 6 looks good
they always delaying their game where's
avatar we don't know but then you got
certain studios that i'm just like they
don't they they kind of miss for me yeah
comiac for now even when i said
overdrive yeah yeah i respect them you
know what they're probably happy they're
doing this of course they might be their
number one studio they might be doing
these things they got them on the back
yeah they got they've been carrying them
right now what i don't know it's a cgi
trailer that i'm just like wait to that
game gameplay come out i need to see the
game horse of course yeah all right
that i gotta get my balls if we go no
it's just that as it it's you know it
it's
first of all nobody on twitter's
bothered me about this stuff
no no no no no nobody
[Laughter]
they watch the show
nobody bothered me and first of all
everybody knows oh i'm going to support
these big titles i'm going to go play
these games to the end i'm going to go
beat all these valkyries for sure i'm
just telling dudes and they know now
when i told you that it was dlc
it is because when they said we getting
the asgard
okay
now i might disagree with the dlc part i
mean we could argue about a lot of games
that come out with sequels
listen gears 5.
they did the other stuff that it was dlc
though right call it like it is but they
can't because they're trying to make
that butt off i think what he's saying
3mg ricky is
there's a lot of studios out there that
have ideals for something and it and
they spin that as like a new like a
whole game instead of you know back in
the day we used to call it how it is
even they did this is a standalone
expansion right now
already i call out two games right now
overwatch too
shouldn't even be overwatch two yeah
overwatch ones an upgrade and honestly
destiny of course that's today see but
but then it's like you know people would
argue back and forth and i'm like nah
man they didn't have to do that because
now they're talking about how destiny 2
is going to what they're going to make
sure that lasts for a long time but like
yeah there's games like that there is
definitely games like that so you know i
don't know finish it okay because i get
everything no i'm done okay
that i really pretty much need to say um
i didn't like to start initially the
intro was a goofy flex i didn't like the
chess game thing i wasn't it was about
that you know and look to king's point
yes initially
a lot of multi-platform stuff which
surprised me that they spent that much
time
you know doing that keep in mind to see
the people at mike sony was hyping this
up too yeah for sure for sure for sure
you know but to solve credit i thought
the kotor was a a very powerful move
it's a subtle powerful move because it
was just like look we we got something
that we know the pulse of hardcore
gamers want which is arguably some
people consider that even the best
bioware game shout out to my co-host
maddie plays like he he went crazy
people were literally like almost in
tears with this thing now granted
like king of sand and atticus and we
don't know about the developer the
history with them is not necessarily the
strongest like you know what ghost is
saying but the the fact that it was
announced to me is is a big deal and the
fact is exclusive foreign the thing that
no one's talking about that's really
forespoken
for spoken looked amazing to me that
looked
crazy then amy amy hennig's on it
nope
on it
it looks phenomenal
that game i don't know how nobody's
talking about that game that game looked
crazy to me
i don't get
it
i don't get it because like it's got the
names with wida and hennig there yeah
it's got the names yeah
just something about it i could not have
been more lukewarm on it okay okay but i
don't i can't place my finger on what it
is because those two names are so
revered listen so revered i get it you
know it's not for everybody to me i just
look at it like hey exclusive it looked
great you know i like the pedigree
behind it amy she makes my legacy of
kane my favorite you see that's i'm all
in for the quality of the team behind it
but um yeah you know the the god of war
i see what sort of saying you know i
thought it was listen i'm with king
i wasn't expecting like oh my god it's
going to change the game graphically
whatever whatever based on the time
frame is more of the same and i know
they're going crazy with the bolt
innovation but the end of the day we
ain't going to act like when they drop
it ain't most likely going to be quality
based on the pedigree right we ain't
going to act like we ain't going to play
it right we see fat thor and all that we
in you know what i said so
i'm there and the same thing like as far
as um the superhero stuff i mean just
insomniac was just flexing it was just
it i did not expect spider-man this soon
like already like dude i know you you
mean it came out in 2018 morales was
basically dlc i don't know why they made
it as a standalone and then of course
yeah so but of course like it was
certainly a flexing to let it be known
that you guys love
like this last spider-man remember
they've been dropping spider-man games i
guess
i guess the reason it didn't surprise me
is because i know that they are very
open to showing games a couple years out
so like
you know you can even ask the hustle
like i actually said in the attic show
that i didn't think spider-man would be
here but it wouldn't surprise me if it's
here because you know
wolverine caught me off guard spider-man
or wolverine
i didn't even know yeah
spider-man was one of those things oh
spider-man too i guess it's sooner than
we yeah
that's one of his biggest
yeah so look the only thing i'm going to
say to counter kings i feel very
extremely difficult with the cgi is like
we got to stop with this always cji
don't count and the reason why i'm not
with keg on this is because at the end
of the day we the same ones we're the
same get let's that's how i look at it
the cgi is okay when you announce hey
we're working on something guys we're
the same people that says let's see go
yes he goes yeah and then we can't be
like yo cgi is whack we couldn't be
doing that then you show pre-alpha
footage you'll be like oh dawg dawg why
you should have kept that to yourself
look at that rock then they look at that
boat animations see so it's like we
can't have it both ways we can't get mad
at the devs when they show us pre-alpha
and because we want game play you know
what i'm looking like with this boat
stuff
i feel like craig remember when i didn't
know what happened with craig yeah like
i really don't know what's going on with
this boat stuff i saw the damn trailer
it was like it was something pretty
weird it was the the boat stuff is
really yeah i think the whole stuff took
a
kind of life of his own but i agree with
him where i'm back with king on siege i
don't mind it on your first announcement
yes first one you get one you get one
just let us oh you're making that great
guys
now the next one i don't want to see no
more cgi
that's
show me the concept the vertical slice
now it's time to play but other than
that look it was it was a solid show i i
did give it an eight i felt it was uh
the beginning show third party
multiplies but i felt that multi plats
were decent games that people were going
to be interested that's coming to them
this year whatever and it to me is that
that michael jordan effect you could
have when you're the market leader you
could afford to have mm-hmm
for one through three quarters
but in the fourth quarter and you
dropped some oh my god they did the
wolverine from three
and you throw the hands up like
bro
it brings the wonder the theatrics the
hope they they got it and to king's
point he's right 20 24 20 25 hardcore
gamers no that ain't coming out no
doubts right
[Music]
we got to give jim ryan this the man is
a business man he knows what
his fingers on the pulse of pop culture
and what casual and i bet you one
they're getting a wolverine for them
because of jim ryan because he sees
what's popping what's popular he sees
mcu
and it's just like look like you gotta
hand it to the man like look although a
lot of people don't agree with what this
man's doing in the playstation ecosystem
but i bet you 20 bucks by the end of
this generation he has made more money
for playstation than anyone else i think
i think you're getting in a wolverine
game because of insomnia oh for sure i
think oh i get that but i think yeah
he was the aggressive one to get the
license i think insomniac has a board
of who they want and what they need
and when you're leading the package
doing
you know why i know you're right is
because when we saw the internal
documents from jason schreyer about why
we're not getting a days going sequel
and everything now is being shifted to
naughty dog what jim ryan is doing in my
opinion is he's making a studio
hierarchy he's saying oh these dudes the
money makers over here these last of us
yeah we putting them up so you know what
that new game that you thought you was
going to do
you going to get over there you're gonna
help get this game across the finish
line and we're gonna do another remake
of the last of us you know they got to
prove yourself you get the blank check
exactly and now the zombie act has shown
not only of equality they workers they
could put out a bunch not only you you
you know okay yeah i'll i'll and i'll
add on another individual which i was
going to ask you guys all of this
question
y'all would y'all ever want to see hideo
kojima make a game for xbox oh no
that's a given and i think that same
regard where sony i remember that press
conference they basically allowed him
oh yeah they left him with everything
they let him whatever they let him go
wow you know what i like that i want an
action game
though i don't want that
i don't know what ups simulator
oh
baby
little baby didn't hit like it was
supposed to and even sony respected the
fact that it didn't hit because he
didn't really pull back yeah they put
improvements
yeah yeah
i do i do want to piggyback off what
cognito said like he he's setting a
hierarchy over there
and i personally still don't see if
sonic is their best one i think that
that's their most efficient studio
but until they make a last of us two
caliber or god of war caliber i can't
give them that but what they're doing
over there is they they're encouraging
competition do you want to be our number
one person they're encouraging like the
day's gone ben studios like look do you
want to be with insomniac and get you
know you get to make what you want you
got to prove yourself you're building a
hierarchy man i agree i'll finish it
that's pretty much it look
like everyone i agree with everyone's
opinion on some level it's just funny i
just feel like he appealed jim ryan did
a good job
of why he's the moneymaker of appealing
we're going to say it's remaking the
same formula great but he appeals to
that character he has his finger on the
pulse so i'll read the super chats let's
combine the last two and get about it oh
my lord okay
it's like
okie dokie
and just how you want to do
let's just do these last two and then do
them all at once
all right so the last two topics that
they just blame everybody right all
right cool this will be quick um soft
mid game refreshes and yeah like yeah
i'll grab him infinite flight ill
so yeah uh shout out to wccf tech and um
moore's law is dead from youtube um so
moore's laws that is a as a youtuber um
he's actually good stuff he was recently
on uh
colin's show and they were just talking
about industry stuff because this guy
has access to a lot of sort of behind
the scenes sort of information
and
on both the xbox and the playstation
size he's saying we're gonna get
refreshes by 2022 2023 for both consoles
on the xbox side he's saying that uh the
s is going to kind of lead the charge
with the refresh uh probably using a new
smaller six nanometer uh apu faster
clocks more cores stuff like that just
to to make that console even more
competitive and on the playstation side
there's two sort of rumors uh so on the
xbox side
they're saying that we're not going to
see any sort of improvement to the x
maybe to 2023 or beyond um on the
playstation side 2022 2023 they're
talking about a ps5 slim which will be
cheaper than the current you know
whatever base 400 model in addition to
the pasta this is where he lost me a
little bit but in addition to the
possibility of an 8k ps5 pro
they would be running in the range of
600 to 800 dollars
nobody asked for that i don't want no
consoles dropping
like it's bad enough these games are
taking years to develop and we only got
what one got a war out of the whole
console gen like yo drop like two three
bangers before you drop another console
so
on the surface right you look at this
you look at this on the surface you're
like
they can't even get us consoles right
now why are they talking about other
skus and new skus
when they talk about smaller processors
though right the six nanometer
processors at the end of the day that
would help production because what
happens is that the wafer that they that
they create to take the silicon from is
what they need from it now is smaller so
there's less waste you'll be able to get
more chips off of each wafer so and
technically you could you could put out
more machines that way um so we'll see
if that happens but what do you guys
feel about the fact that we're even
talking about getting mid-cycle
yeah let's get go because ghost actually
has to leave like right okay you gotta i
know everybody's gonna leave so let's
get the ghost and i also want to sneak
in go you're playing on the mid-gen
refreshers and we're gonna buy halo
infinite multiplayer flight are you
excited
oh uh well that's easy yes i'm excited
for the multiplayer flight uh especially
because it's now open to every
halo insider which means more people are
going to get to go out there big team
battles in there i think everybody
that's a halo fan you might have to
stream that yeah yeah that's gonna be a
good time for sure
um as far as mid gem refreshes i think
that's a case of gamers being gamers and
saying all right what's next all right
what's next they consume content or they
consume something right away and they're
like alright what's next um real talk
this generation is going to be very long
due to a lot of these shortages and i
think that's just kind of how it goes um
i don't need a refresh for sure like i
thought about getting some
uh some you know
that special edition halo series x but
i'm like yo people can't even get those
things right like
yeah like i'm lucky to have one right
now and i'm jealous of anybody that gets
a halo one but i couldn't justify it in
my mind yeah i see you king
all right i see you all right i'm
wearing your shirt too king
[Music]
but yeah man i mean i don't know how you
can not be excited about the halo
infinite flight this is supposed to be
there big time it's the reboot or
refresh of halo this is their chance to
really have
a one of those like
triple quad a caliber titles that is on
the level with some of those uh sony
franchises so i'm excited to see kind of
what happens as more people get their
hands on it
um did i answer your two questions no
you did you did i just wanted to make
sure you got offload i know you got to
run a lot of stuff going on but we gotta
celebrate you man the xbox expansion
pass
100 episodes brother you're concerned
man
you're one of my up-and-coming young
gunners i call you one of my young
shooters out here doing your thing you
know what i'm saying so i wanted to
celebrate you let the farm people know
where they could find you and what else
is going on with you man
absolutely man i'm so grateful for the
time to get to hang out with you guys
today i always tell the story i met king
in line at e3
for battle toads and that's kind of how
that came to be and so that's really
dope
um
it's just cool i uh
episode 99 drops tonight
at 6 p.m uh eastern with the developers
of skateboard which is coming out day
and date on game pass
that's what we do oh come on man i lost
every i think i see you know i mean
you gotta you gotta look right now yo
you gotta look at at the at the list
look at ghosts
over 40 dev interviews across 99
episodes right now so
it's amazing it's cool it's cool i
appreciate it i got to start poaching
your interviews man yeah man
rising tides lift all boats man
that's all and so
yeah you can find uh xbox expansion pass
on youtube that's it's just the audio
file but it's there for people that
enjoy it on youtube and then all your
podcast services that's how you got my
viewership
hey i'm glad i'm glad to hear it and i
know it's a solo show so it's a little
bit of a different speed right it's just
me yeah um so i hope anybody's willing
to check it out i'm giving away two
controllers for anyone that drops an
itunes review just to try and help
celebrate people that have checked out
this show we might need to get creative
like that to get them eyes
itunes reviews
i'm trying to get to ilp numbers you
know what i'm saying that's what i'm
trying to do
[Music]
[Laughter]
anybody's listening is willing to go
check it out xbox expansion pass all
your podcast services youtube put it in
the chat man put it in the chat yeah oh
yeah yeah i'll be happy to but uh real
talk just give it a shot if it's your
speed stick around if not no hard
feelings i appreciate anybody that gives
it a look for sure no doubt i'm gonna
hook them up right now
that's the youtube joint right there
he's primarily on audio but again if you
don't want to do the audio thing you
prefer it on youtube put the youtube
joint out there yo salute to the ghost
man you'll be holding it down good to
see your continued success uh one
episode 100 do your thing brother you
already know mad love enjoy your sunday
bro thank you thank you to all and 3mg
it was nice to meet you and it was a
pleasure my brother man always
all right addicts of king cog
have a good one brother
i know you're up next first you gotta go
you gotta make that money soon so um
you got going off with these topics
first
uh so i mean like when it comes to
the whole cross gin thing like making
another you guys know how i felt about
the series the xbox one x and the xbox
one yeah no no thank you like not not
even a little bit like because to me you
know then you're gonna have incidences
where people have to make you know
different other platforms and i don't
mind it as long as it makes sense i
guess it made more sense with the xbox
one because it
but
i'm just like look like i don't want
none of that like i want everyone on the
same hardware like it's just i know it's
gonna happen oh my god i know it's gonna
happen
it's just like i hated like like
incidences where now it's just like
i don't want the cell phone model i just
don't like it and i feel like if we keep
giving these leeways we're going to
eventually be buying a new system every
two years
i don't want that to happen because with
the whole you know i i say this all the
time i played
gears 5 of kid smooth he was on the xbox
one x and i was on the xbox one s
and that was the prime example of why
i'll never be on the list system ever
again because we're playing gears 5 we
died
it's already loaded on homeboys
[Music]
i'm sitting there in the loading screen
and the games lie
and all the people are coming around to
kill me kids news is happening
and i'm just sitting here like and we
all know sometimes kid's smooth you know
ain't the greatest again so like i'm
just sitting here like like i'm like kid
i'm like just there's a couple more
seconds he's like how long is this gonna
take
me i'll feel you bro and what about what
about oh so clearly you're not you're
not for the [ __ ] refreshments
multiplayer flight big team battle where
we act
man we streaming
we because i loved what i played earlier
we're going to play that big team battle
so we're going to have a little bit more
people might get some people from the
community to play with us man like i
like what they're doing i want to see
more i want like all i know is all these
tech issues
all these tech technical tests i better
not have no issues day one
because it's just like you you've had
plenty of and i love that they're doing
this they're trying to make sure they
don't have issues they want i want to
play more halo no let more halo is
always good and we're about to play some
more you know hopefully we'll get ricky
play with this a little bit he's down
man i'm down
i i i definitely got to take off because
i got some stuff i got to do
i appreciate everyone for coming through
man
we had up to like 634
[Music]
[Laughter]
man i feel bad for for saul like the
super chats is crazy
i'm good i'm good i got i got water i'm
good
okay
do your thing also your announcement
with your your new co-host on the ad oh
i announced that but um
so you know keep that in mind
he's like i'm not going to repeat that
i was going to say that but i i didn't
know if you heard it
because you know people don't realize
how much you know streaming how much
podcasting it's not something that you
could just commit to like it's something
that you have to revolve your life
around like once i don't want to yeah
it's it and you know that's why when me
and carl were talking because i've been
in this this this this realm of choosing
someone for a while i you know i've done
a couple with hustle and then me and
carter talking you know there's a couple
people that came up but ain't nobody
wanted more than hustle
and that's why i was like look you know
hustle has always been there he's always
been in the chat he's always been you
know uh very active in the community you
could tell he wants the podcast a lot of
people think that just talking about
something is the difference than
actually doing it week-to-week
always been there and just like you know
i i tweeted about it you know you'll see
him more in our reactions our community
shows uh because you know we want to
reward people that go out there and they
show what they want facts put
out hustle and motivate out here moving
and shaking that's what's up baby dmv
stand up i get your money we already
know what it is let's get on my boy
ricky ricky what's up man um real quick
so mid gen refreshes fan
yay nay and then also halo infinite uh
multiplayer flight with the big team
battle are you excited okay so uh
mid gen reef no
okay no i'm gay i'm good i'm good for
another playstation like
no profile no no scorpios no no nothing
honestly like and we got like we're
gonna spend another 800 like 800 bucks
and like you got that buddy come on down
here
netflix on my playstation
i i ain't with that man it's only i
don't even know why they're even
announcing that right now with the
shortages but no no mid gem refreshes as
far as halo goes ain't nobody's going to
tell me nothing about hillary clinton
here nobody can tell me now i'm going to
play that as soon as it was september
24th yeah yeah
yep so we in there i'm down if y'all oh
yeah yeah no problem
all come together guys let's do it let's
do it let's get the old cool let's do it
man for sure but i'm loving that and you
would you said flight or something like
that yeah so basically he's a
multi-player fight because remember the
first ones were like versus the bots but
this is okay okay okay oh yeah yeah
yo but oh their ai was kind of
they were in a bag
i said whoa i felt like i was garbage
and i'm liking that um that area too
like you really thought like i really
felt like i was playing other um people
online but um no this one we're going up
against other people i'm hyped for a big
team battles it's always been part of
the og so like i'm ready for it no no
doubt you already know soft oh actually
it's your time so
i'll get you in on it what's far because
it's two so basically
are you with it
the midgame reference and then the multi
what the uh halo
the thing about it is that
like last gen you understood why there
was a gen refresh those consoles were
were
two years late
they were underpowered by the time we
got them so i kind of understand trying
to extend that life
you know by all accounts they they had
said they they rectified that right
that's not the case with the both of
these consoles both the playstation and
the xbox
by those by their accounts so i honestly
wasn't necessarily expecting that again
unless they want to now extend console
generations to 10 years
then okay i get it
but they've never made that clear that
that's what they wanted to do so these
extensions again what you you know
you're gonna get
higher resolution you're gonna be able
to hit true 4k
or whatever the case may be uh 120 fps
on more games stuff like that so i i get
it for those reasons i get it for the
reasons of being able to to use the
smaller chip and be able to get more
consoles out in the wild and then thus
dropping the price of the ones that are
already out in the market i get all that
oh i'm not necessarily a fan man like
the stupid thing is i'm gonna be there
in the carpet right i'm going to buy it
like you got you're not going to count
that [ __ ] smackdown you talking
you're going to hold it live you're
going to hold a lot yeah we
got to create this man it's like yeah
you got to do it
we got to preface everything with our
fraud
the playstation pro was definitely good
if you had the vr mm-hmm right if you
didn't don't yeah it definitely boosted
and it definitely helped you
um
i i really other than that i don't i
didn't see the necessary reasons
um the xbox uh scorpio
uh phil needed to put his stamp on the
situation because let's be real man the
2013 the vcr was garbage
like it was garbage it was garbage so he
had to go in there and fix that and gain
you know the power narrative
these consoles don't need it
well how about y'all stop supporting
last gen and just support this one
and we don't have to worry about next
gen or [ __ ] and just do
if they really cut off last gen if y'all
believe in generations like y'all say
you believe in generations y'all cut
them off god of war wouldn't look like
that
right so let's just stop playing around
with everybody money trying to dig in
everybody's wallet all over again and it
ain't gonna be that much different from
what you see and a lot of you dudes
don't have the televisions
you know why because these dudes out
here talk about yeah man can't wait for
the night
at that vr these are the same dudes that
go inside best buy and don't go to that
wall they don't go to the back
are you
and said you know what
you know only the impulse purchases
they're picking their tv up off the
floor you know what they say it said 4k
i got a 4k playstation
this is that's what they do
you get in the house you got the tcl uh
at tcl you're like oh yeah man i'm next
janet i'm doing this and then you got a
bunch of x oh not not check marks in the
back of your joint you know see
what i'm talking about is real tv people
mm-hmm
sovereign knows
when he walks in best buy those things
on the floor stink to him oh my god he
walks to the wall and say yes what's
this is this twenty twenty decisions i
don't care
with my televisions
right so these dudes are supposed to be
bougie with the you got to play station
five and still playing on a bubble bat
listen
and i've seen it already
i've seen it already
take advantage of what you got some of
you guys don't need it so when you see
it pop up and i'm just i'm just teaching
you something really quickly
when your hardware matches your other
hardware then you good yeah right
quality so take take your money
and make sure all those check marks is
checked on your tv
when you hook your console up to it
right so you're not excluded from this
gen
stop worrying about 8k
just get what you got right now and
elevate your tv don't worry about those
consoles because they're not going to do
anything different for you i don't like
the next gen refresh i think we needed
it last time we don't need it now
just leave last gen in the past that's
all just leave it in the past let's get
to let's let's work on what we got now
we we haven't maximized nothing now i
feel you i feel you're going nothing you
don't ever
come out you know they take advantage of
it it's just it's business y'all you
know it's just too many
old there's too many playstation 4's in
a while there's too many xbox ones in a
while the the boardroom is looking at
that money you know what i'm saying and
i know gamers don't like it
but i don't see them stopping i really
don't i think
my my gut is that they use that as a
test bed
for for last gen and they're looking at
it like look
com usually this type of stuff is
reserved for the pc space in my opinion
we grab upgrade your graphic card you
upgrade to this to me
gamers empowered them to look at them
and say you know what they did buy that
ps4 pro though
they did buy that scorpio though so so
there's a subset of gamers that power
does matter and they want the latest and
greatest so i think they may i don't
know what all the metrics are i don't
have that but there's a part of me that
does feel that there may be some truth
to this these are all rumors i mean i
still think it's farther away i think
this is gonna happen yeah i think it's
gonna happen i i just think like i think
this generation will be a long
generation longer generation because
they would they came out more at power
at the same time they're gonna buy huh i
mean
oh wow
wow i'm not gonna buy they fooled me
once already
i'm not gonna buy it
because
i'm not going to buy
right because i don't believe what
they're saying
right okay i will get a playstation
whatever if it ever drops i don't
believe
or whatever whatever the next xbox is
but that refresh bro you done
you're not getting me y'all through the
bananas
there you get through the banana in the
tailpipe already with the power you a
power guy and you know what you ain't
gonna put the double check marks on the
check mark that's right there
like on my tv
it's not gonna get double check marks
and you don't have no ak times
substantially but they better
if okay so let's say god of war does
come out and god of war is native 8k
and can be displayed on your television
8k no tv so then guess who's got to go
get one
but you know what they not
and we've been hopeful all the time
and it's just not gonna it's just your
whole thing is i get you you there's
gonna be a lot of caveats
to see
a certain level we gotta put our foot
down
you know we gotta put our foot down like
we we really do because
we allowing these dudes to dictate pace
to us
yeah and we have to dictate pace to them
yeah all right so there's no 8k content
so i i can see if this 8k content there
there's no 8k drives in the disk drive
you got no 8k movies this is not
necessary right so please guys i don't
want y'all to feel like y'all have to
get 700 800 dollars up and other things
that's lacking fix those other things up
and and that's the thing though
that's another thing that that eight
seven eight hundred dollar stuff and
nowhere is that console coming out at
that price oh it's not gonna happen yeah
i agree
it's still gonna be under power and
competitiveness right so that's the
thing right you're going to get
the point of bringing these out is to
drop the price of the one that's already
out right so and this one's going to
take that price point right you're not
you're not going to be paying more than
500 for whatever these consoles are i
think that's that's the max you'll be
paying yeah so for 500
the upgrade that you're probably going
to get isn't going to be super
substantial so when you start hearing 8k
and all that nah i'm just going to um
shout out to my last word co-host but
the cheaters in here ibontis he said
yeah ak so far away he said 4k 60
doesn't run all features locked at 60.
even a beast booster gpu and other
things and a refresh isn't going to do
it and um yeah so pretty much he's he's
in agreement with usoff
yeah man i just it's not it's it's very
it's weird that they've been talking
about it but again
this means that it's coming like king
said it's coming i don't 20 and then
2022 it's like really that seems too
fast
that's a slap in the face yeah yeah no i
agree
but anybody that got it and we didn't
even touch the surface
you're talking about your dip in your
water i agree right now for this even to
be look i can understand it in the way
development works in the back end they
got to be talking about it internally
but they're going to be upset yeah but
to to to say like yo we plan on
announcing it yeah that's just way too
soon and i completely but we got to move
on all right get up out of here super
chats um before we do let me get the
poll because i always forget the po i
forgot it last time it did oh forget
about it here so new ilp log that poll
with the recent announcements of marvel
spider-man 2 and wolverine developed
exclusively for playstation 5. do you
think xbox also needs to have its own
marvel dc
aaa narrative driven superhero game king
is shaking his head hey yes
with microsoft's resources in reach
there is no reason why this successful
genre is lacking in their portfolio b no
xbox does not need to copy sony's
template for success and should continue
to develop diverse experiences or c i
don't care if xbox don't get
just one i'm watching cog flip on
[Laughter]
this space
an absolute pleasure to have you around
thank you guys
brother where can i find people find you
what you got going on sir you know we
just uh again we just be streaming a
whole bunch of different games you know
to pass the time until sony finally
drops something for your boy i'll be
playing all types of board games sports
games rpgs all over party games with the
homies um twitch youtube social media
twitter and instagram all three of you
live y'all can find me there man yo i
appreciate this yeah i told you i could
talk man i love you in games um
can't you a funny dude
funny dude is funny because chase said
the same thing when he was on the show
he goes man that guy king i like him
yeah at the end of the day it's all the
same thing like you know you know we
don't like getting got by no companies
man that's crazy but ball gaming is all
love man i appreciate y'all so much my
brother appreciate you man i love what
you're doing i remember you know just
when i'm on my one and two and i would
be at the shows and i see you you know
saying moving and shaking out there a
couple times with bg shout out to i
forgot to mention you know what one of
your og toys whatever happened to
brooklyn's skill treat remember that oh
man whatever brooklyn skill treat you bg
and ray what's that
that was fire man it was really
scheduling because you know
you know he had work she had work and i
had work you know i wish it could have
been something now because well even
though i and i moved but had it been
like where this was our dedicated
dedicated spaces in our form of like
what we can do now for a living it would
have been so much easier
that was the only they were really just
scheduling and making sure that we was
actually free yeah
i really enjoyed it yeah i've been
following for a minute and i remember
that and i was like kid i was like yo
that's something that's dope like
they're doing it in three dope content
creators doing an in-person
podcast you know what i'm saying from
the town
you know what i'm saying but i salute to
you and that's all we can find people
find you what you got going on you know
what's up man i'm actually going to work
so i haven't said that in a long time
i'm going to work today jesus so you
know doing nothing uh waiting on death
later this week i probably won't be able
to play it until saturday next week but
uh i'm excited to see what people think
of that because uh i love arcane i love
arcane i want it and i want i want
arcane
sir
no doubt egg lord king spicy as ever so
disrespectful to be so disrespectful
[Laughter]
um
first and foremost 3mg oh my god
it's it's always good to to talk to
somebody from the town that um
knows our struggle i ain't necessarily
not saying that in california struggling
not saying wisconsin west virginia over
here boston whatever they don't have
trouble we have struggle all over this
earth all right but i can identify with
this man in his struggle i can identify
with this man talking about he got to do
this to make sure this happened and
instills a work ethic within himself and
his work that
has built what he has
and i respect it thank you because it's
it's very hard you understand but when
you love something that comes easy when
you love it you understand and
you said something that you burnt out on
gta
you had to switch it up
when you switched it up you didn't lose
anybody you probably gained more people
like wow he could do this other stuff
you understand but you said you found
yourself and you was being true to
yourself
yeah man that's what people deal with
that's what people love that's why
people tune in you yeah so i respect you
yo i had so much fun today yeah yeah oh
no today was great
but listen man i salute you and i salute
all your hard work and thank you i i
love the fact that you understand
business tie
i mean this you understand like i really
respect that thank you so much for
coming through for everybody that's
trying to figure out what i got spinning
in the background um that's a memorial
to my boy chris uh you can check out uh
on the dcx channel uh legion of doom
episode three um when we just celebrate
the life of my boy chris nelson
um
gone too quick and and and it really
hurts when you start to reflect on
things i was just texting a bunch of
people yesterday that i haven't been in
contact with just to tell them i love
them um kos is up so you can see the red
room yeah y'all keep asking me and y'all
keep thinking this is the only room
go to see the kos and go see the red
room see what the red room do
and tell me what you think leave
comments down at the bottom because cog
is always telling me you're talking and
i got to go over there and i got to
answer you guys
and i'm going to answer each and every
last one um leave something ask me some
questions uh and i get that stuff done
go to lords of gaming.net which is the
best gaming news site
i don't think ign can hold the candy
toilet why we gotta disrespect rj we
can't believe it
why we can't just be nice without
disrespect
and i want to compete i feel that we
want to we got we got people over there
we got friends over there i i love them
i love it i love you man but i want them
to work with us
all right this is you assimilating them
like the boys okay so the same way y'all
saw that right okay keep the same
energy you
microsoft i want them to get sony
i really want to assimilate shout out to
travis shout out to ryan
shout out to all the ign people that
we've had on that's my people miranda
all right
you don't say brandon you don't say it
no doubt yes
yes come this way so look we got a ton
of super chats we got to read what i
want to do is we got to let we can't
keep ricky hostage here so bro yeah do
your blades we're going to pay the bills
you know what i'm saying but it was an
absolute pleasure you know you always
welcome back to wrong meetings
we got to do something we got to do
something for real yeah
i'll drop you on my numbers in the damn
stuff like that you got to get right man
please and then when it shows open back
up we definitely got a link too that's
another thing oh
yeah okay so the last one i have is a
bonus is just in case anything comes in
afterwards you're gonna watch that
let me scroll backwards
we got less
some vendetta brian give me a moment
i'm so upset that y'all did show up this
early in the morning
madness
i'm ready you ready
all right cool
got clutch man 10 super chat wolverine
and venom reveal was great dt honestly i
didn't didn't look as photo realistic as
forza horizon 5. last time i scored 40
percent on the test the teacher failed
me
yo
again for minimal effort
done
real quick before i forget we got two
people that uh cop merged one body cop
the ilp the new unity tv you unity
t-shirt so salute to him put your name
in there you know what i'm saying
and somebody else just cop a crest shirt
too at 11 this morning so smooth and in
case you guys have not seen it we got
backpacks now
[Music]
baby
you got it oh yes sir hit that t store
let's go have the kitties
let's do it
then we got done otaku two dollar super
chat i got a vizio oled do i get a pass
kid
no done
don't do that don't do it don't do that
don't bring the costco special oh
i love you though don't do that
there we go cowboys fan 404 ten dollars
if phil spencer announced they acquired
tltcl king king would
his king's tune would change when they
drop a bag watch what happened yeah
i don't care iop will be the official
sponsor of tc
i don't care what phil's saying they
like the sony and lg they understand
greatness god bless
then we got l boogie 10 super chat no
date god of war and wolverine have no
data here for the smoke they do got a
date l 20 23 20 25.
[Laughter]
yeah we got cowboys fan five dollars
with that tcl my bad
put tlc in the other one
crazy then we got jd gamer 10 super chat
okay let me just admit right off off the
bat to the playstation showcase had four
to five games that i'm going to need to
play
i.e ps5 is coming with those bangers
insomniac has ascended to godhood but
when can i play them that's the question
probably sooner than the next naughty
dog game though
that's probably true no no the next
noted game is on pc stop playing
remate
remix yeah we got lady infamous in the
house ten dollar super chat the new god
of war looks like dlc but i'm still
going to mess with it and it's true
as we all are you know
dlc
then we got jd gamer 10 chat
what if anything needs to be done how
should microsoft respond to the kotor
remake on ps5 and wolverine
should microsoft go on a buying spree
that includes all of dc or should they
go
for black panther punisher they don't
need to do anything just let them be yo
let them smoke they got so much studios
and they're putting out so many games
you can't be the master very thick all
right tell me this please just put one
tell me this what what if they're one
is hulk
oh green the green green with the green
green
okay
i was hyped when they had that marvel
mmo that was supposed to be coming yeah
they shelved it for whatever reason and
at the end at the end of the day
wherever the games go i'm gonna go of
course do i feel like microsoft need to
have this to compete no
i don't but if they have it it's good
but if sony makes it i'm over there
sure
i just think he fits with the xbox yeah
he does
things
[Music]
the art of game wars dictates that
microsoft should go out there and
prevent playstation from having a safe
sector they should attack them in every
genre harass them and acquire their
customers
the rest of them
you know what it is when people hear me
say i want them assimilated i want to
destroy they really go to the extreme
and you know what and you say how is
that you doing the same thing
yeah
i would really love to have all the
games over there
absolutely then we have lord metroid two
dollars super chat good sony showcase
but less execs yapping stop it wow and
that was like i mean i like it at the
end at the end of the day
i love that i love it i love that gym
yeah you had jim ryan introduced a
little bit then you had herman host a
little bit but it was quick i was fine
with that yeah i didn't mind that all
right let me go home that's what i said
the wise old game of 5 super chat the
more i reflect on it the more i can
relate to the playstation like me it
only comes two to three four times
telling me right now i would like to
just sit there and get bears with him
yeah he's the last reason let me get a
lady information to find out a super
chat shout out to chrome women gaming
there is no console war when you have
everything factual facts i still look at
the other one with the side eye
[Music]
yeah yours is coughing up
then we have emery five dollars for chat
no the tcl 8k tv the r648 is the most
impressive tv on the market it's solid
all around kings show the pictures of it
show your pictures in your receipt
don't tell me what it do you show me
what it do
guys
bro don't try to downplay that boat
animation super mario 64 had completely
different animations the super mario
world no
assets
excuses
not the same game
y'all guys want too much from this god
of wars
here we got rrd five dollar super chat
when you're in the drought even dasani
sounds amazing yo
explains why some so many guys thought
this show was amazing more multi-plat
sure just give me
i told you
shout out to horace with the two hours
of chat jimmy dance moves put a molly
[Music]
luke how much did you like resistance
trilogy so i guess we'll have to ask
luke later let me get the next one
christopher
jetzer find out super chat i heard that
microsoft is focusing on lucasfilms
where saudi has marvel also special dick
says indiana jones is exclusive xbox
needs more interest i'm gonna highlight
at special day they do
listen i i'm excited for indiana yeah of
course indiana jones is not a property
that's going to appeal to the use today
it's just not nobody that know him now
if you clint eastwood you might remember
that game exactly but i'm a holiday xbox
era special dick salute to those guys
hopefully we will be working on
something yeah i'll find out what else
we got then we got jw as a shill five
dollar super chat guys
i thought playstation guys didn't buy
players five to play old games what
happened
on the side note looks like the real ps5
will release in 2023.
alvin follow super chat i thought i
think phil saw the table of western rpgs
they already have and said it's not
worth outbidding sony for this thank you
that's what i said yeah but you know
what that i mean again maybe their
thinking changed but when they say they
spent a hundred million on rise of the
tomb raider i was like what the i was
shocked you needed it though you don't
need it now 100 mil they have too much
going down like they don't need it
okay excuse me um the professor five
dollar super chat when i hear cross play
can't thank microsoft the sony have to
thank epic games
yeah pushing for that to happen right
shout out to epic games for
for uh
sort of they're being disruptive and
kind of sort of a beating apple on the
on the counts that matter yes so
and we have donald tackle two super chat
uh pg fables writer has done dishonored
and control
very nice jw is a shield 10 super chat
so 130 million playstation 4 is out
there and yet sony continues to put
games on pc and other consoles can we
stop seeing the playstation fanboy
supports fanbase supports playstation
games if that was true mlb would not be
on xbox
well i think jim is a businessman and
he's going to get money every way he can
so and he released it on playstation 4
playstation 5 game pass and pc yeah it's
more revenue streams because the person
with the business uh acronym knows the
more revenue streams you have the more
money you get yeah that mlb was more out
of their hands than obviously it's not
their it's not really their license you
know what i mean but uh yeah they could
have turned around old playstation
old playstation old playstation might
have been like you know what i guess
we're done making baseball games what we
had a date with that boot
it's out of your hands
i'm done she's going out on tuesday
remake is going to be an unmitigated
disaster it is my absolute favorite game
in the history of gaming and i refuse to
play anything that rewrites it it was
perfect before yeah so apparently um
there's a little bit of drama around
this because one of the writers of the
new game said that there were things
that
she did not appreciate about the old
game that
were going to be changed and hardcore
fans some departure fans kind of um
[Laughter]
uh then we have amblix two dollars super
chat uh niners nations let's go thanks
for that
then we have muhammad diallo uh with the
35
czar i'd have to look that up and see
what that is uh which mcu game has sold
more than elder scrolls specifically
skyrim
are you doing numbers that's what you do
you have this talking about the park
yeah skyrim a million times
we're about to do it again yep then we
got drunken ninja five dollar super chat
preach addict i've been calling for a
punisher game since the og one from
2005. that game was awesome by the way a
punisher game can show people that xbox
can get serious i don't know who played
that og xbox punisher game but that game
was excellent it was so much fun nobody
that's why i didn't have a sequel
but it was great though it was great
oh then we have jean-marc louis two
dollars with a chat phil saying what
more i gotta do for these gamers
[Music]
[Laughter]
after
we got um danger uxo 5
is sony the next sega damn oh yeah i
think so oh here we go i want them to be
their developer because they're really
good at it they they're really good at
that part of me good they haven't made
really good consoles and this is this we
at it now let's go make your games let
me get laughing it's the cure with the
ten dollars to a chat f4 all that go
across the street and get an exclusive
dc game like justice league be the
behemoth that you are microsoft they can
still build their studios and make the
side deals like so there you go there
you go walk through gum and walk at the
same time there you go let's go these
guys as well then we got
phase all double 07. 4.49 pounds stupid
four
king david what about the game about the
statue ex-punisher from the coalition uh
xbox has to do good with first patch of
release games mm-hmm
it's a quality thing that we have hard
to find five dollar super chat all y'all
gotta do is get king to take off his
[ __ ] he'll start making sense that wow
no i understand sometimes you see the
glare and you don't know if those are my
eyeballs
and it confuses you
[Laughter]
so you won't see my eyes so you can stop
being confused here you go yeah all
right now let's bring it back to sanity
and get back
[Laughter]
there we go laughing and secure 10 super
chat sony just bought inside me i get
they have put out three to four games
already microsoft wants to be the master
of everything all these ips they have
but don't allow their games to grow
where where are the sequels i think that
that's
valid old microsoft battery yeah not now
i would have said yeah yeah definitely
then we got joshua 10 super chat i have
to disagree with you and i haven't liked
any sony games since the playstation 2.
i think all their games are the same and
quite frankly they've got extremely
sterile they've gotten extremely sterile
and boring
yeah they definitely there's a pattern
to their games
but
for whatever reason
when people think triple a that's what
they look at okay
yup exactly
20 super chat what fighting game does
playstation have none there's a weird
perception that sony does all these
things nintendo has by far the most
popular critically acclaimed and best
known games minecraft is bigger than all
others all right we're getting into
semantics
they literally exactly essentially
street fighter is theirs now um and then
they bought evo mm-hmm like it's been
there yeah it's been there it's like you
know what i'm saying like street fighter
that's it like street fighter the game
that was everywhere this is only the
street fighter
you want to play it you know what to buy
laughing is the cure again follow super
chat we can't do it with halo gears and
forza man all these studios and no
triple a exclusive games since 2016 we
need competition with games somebody's
got to go
you know it's crazy i really don't think
you got game pass
like i really think now that you just
woke up from 2013 and you're still
yelling out hey little girls and forza
like
dude they just purchased 27 students man
if you don't go turn on your game passes
[Music]
yeah he says since 2016. we got yeah we
got gears 5. we got like but he did say
without halo gears and forza
go get batman and let it software
developing
and then laughing is the q against the
cure is here boy two dollars over jack
go get an exclusive game from rocksteady
go get rocksteady and then why everybody
want them to do this thing let's say
they doing this really bad
you asked for
then we got flame five dollar super chat
but no no comment from the flame comment
thank you sean hey i'm so i'm surprised
he probably pressed the button too fast
then we got king one supreme ten dollar
super chat
how to beat sony have ninja theory make
a superman game superman can work use
things row four as a template for game
play that and get coalition to make a
mandalorian third person action
adventure game okay so the mandalorian
thing makes sense
you can't make a superman game because
superman is too old to be that's why
there was never any success i agree
i agree superman is too difficult yeah
just because of the character yeah the
character itself is a god so you really
can't do it i agree
all right um laughing is the cue again
two dollar super chat uh let's see what
343 can do making a different game oh
hold on let me get poster that's the
whole post up with the 10 dollar super
chat that opening scene was a subliminal
shot at xbox
telling them that this is chess not
checkers kotor remake and wolverine
proves that we can't outspend you but we
can outmaneuver you oh my god you sat
there and got cerebral with a commercial
like
it was a weak commercial you being okay
you wanna you wanna know what chess and
checkers is testing check is is you
selling 10 million we're selling seven
and we're still making the same amount
of money
what chess and what checkers are you
playing like really what are you doing
you out here selling more making less
you're hustling back
you're talking that money talk that
you know why because they want to sit
there they want to talk money they want
to talk they're making power moves king
things is happening in these streets
what you're witnessing right now that
voice
you you know what a real power move is
your first party baseball game is in
game pass for free for us and you had to
pay for it if that ain't a boss move
that's a checkmate that's like shut down
your computer that's it it's over the
game is over i'm going upside to play
baseball today i don't know
what i'm i'm being petty today i'm going
to go play baseball i'm done
get rich
rachel gave me rewind five dollars which
had possible so when he got first right
of refusal on marvel on consoles when
the spidey mcu deal got made disney
exited games that same year coincidence
probably i mean probably something could
be let me first write a refusal on
everything everything i don't know i
think insomniac has a list and i think
that they yo you know like is it
possible that we can get this yeah if we
can't get this can we get this
you know it's really telling that the
next character that they go to besides
miles because miles was huge but it's in
the spider-man universe and kind of
works
was wolverine and i think wolverine is
the second most popular character that's
inside my age so when you can go to the
to the board
and when we can get the second most
popular character you move two power
pieces off the board facts right so
these two power pieces belong to sony
right now
i'm sorry if you have carl blanche to go
in and say what you want and you take
the two best nah man like
you you had a disadvantage um
they had a disadvantage so don't even go
dc then go dc okay you know but take
that i think you want a brother i think
i think you can you have a better chance
at going at warner brothers and getting
that then even messing with the disney
sony i think you're like
okay okay
that's what i think that you you
actually agree with
yeah it feels that way yeah
then we got mr irishman 10 pound super
chat speaking of xbox marvel games
that's not going to happen anytime soon
one i would love to see is an alien
isolation style horror game with carnage
as the antagonists that's crazy
yeah
super chat sony showcase was
underwhelming where's the variety games
coming years away iop fraud
the xbox game showcase was fire way
better iop book of x yeah well people do
feel the microsoft one still as a whole
was better because
yeah right right right
then we have a lot of roughness
five pound stupid chat you see the
impossible job microsoft had they
knocked it out of the park with the best
showcase this year bar none they don't
need a marvel raffle standing on the
square
no doubt let me get down otaku five
hours of chat the one and ps4 were
underpowered at launch so if refresh
makes sense this gen it makes zero sense
because they're powerful with ai to
stretch the power that's okay exactly
super sampling and all this other stuff
they're talking about that hasn't really
been used in these games don't need it
you know don't really need it yeah we'll
see i don't know jw is a show five
thousand 306 days and no ssd
how am i going to fit spider-man 2
wolverine and god of war 2 of my ps5 oh
wait a second i can just play them on my
ps4
messy the ssds are outside i think the
those mid-jam refreshers is going to
have uh one um two terabytes yeah that'd
be nice
and we got raider blade two pound super
chat i'm late but wolverine is doing the
mlb
man if that happens
you will not hear the end of king that
day that's not happening but that ain't
happening that was big exactly
then we have donald taco two thousand
y'all seeing the red fall leaks it
sounds good so far no i didn't even look
at that i thought away from man i heard
people talk about let me know i'm not
going through that ebatis the last word
my co-host fight out of super chat king
will make you laugh and his blood is
really green but when he gets real it's
from the heart shout out to the full ilv
crew salute blessings jesus blessed
brother blessing bro
you god did you
street fighters capcom not sony you
can't say that's a first party game xbox
and nintendo actually have first party
fighter games perception when you take
a when you take a series like street
fighter and essentially
you you keep it away from everybody else
that is essentially a playstation
franchise now because
because six shows no indication of going
multiplayer
and if it is great fantastic i would
love to play street fighter other than
on the playstation platform
i don't know that it's happening you
know the craziest thing is
if you want to play street fighter 5
you could only do it over here whatever
yes
microsoft needs to bring back spawn
armageddon was dope was it
we missed one let me get donna taco find
out super chat we just gave ryan
mccarthy his roses and now we dissing
his hometown
that's king okay i had to clean that up
with his ign slander listen listen
listen robert cavanaugh first of all um
it's competitive talk all right um i i
am i jealous of their views yes because
i feel that our writers are fantastic
and they own right you know so i will
always shine a light on our riders and
the hard work they do they do put in
absolutely so don't ever think that me
saying something i will tell you don't
go to mcdonald's go to burger king i
don't care
like but at the same time we know that
mcdonald's is number one but we got
burger king flavor baby so let's give it
a buck burger king got that stuff that i
like you know and i'm repping burger
king
what are we doing out here real quick
off super chat boxer says shout out to
49 yes and oh you got your c1 cause your
tv went you got your c1 oled nice old
led in the gang that's what i'm talking
about knocking to you
crap
we got joe dunmore five dollars a week
wolverine is a crosstalk game between
ps5 and ps6
yes we go raider blade again five pound
super chat there is no way that marvel
slash disney would allow xbox to miss
out like spider-man too uh much money
mlb anyone
well what is m d hey mld you made a lot
of money didn't you okay you lost mlb
you probably missed mlb yeah ml i don't
know what ml yeah that's nice
we gonna do that
major league dungeon
julio aroused two dollars super chat
microsoft needs to bring back support
i'm getting i wanna get him with dope i
have to remember if that game was still
put there because the only spawn games
remember i remember the ps1 game that
was horrible it was okay but it was like
you know
because i remember the ps1 one that was
bad no i already read heart kitchen
uh
yeah we got a couple got a couple jd
gamer 10 hour super chat in war you
allow your enemy nothing no peace no
food
tell all devs and publishers to plan to
make content to playstation they will
get more money bid bank big bank take
little bank always
i i feel you but this ain't war
listen listen all right in in in the
conference of the the the board room
that's war right
for us guys you know how you could just
stop the war just go by the other
council
yeah alex there we go alex scores up
five dollars to be chat if xbox can get
static shocked i'll be mind blown
boy don't do me like that
then we got done a taco tuna super chat
the capcom league show street fighter 6
is planned multiplat we shall see
all right jd gamer with a question files
for chat king solve cog tell me what
studio what i p
what move is the death blow that can end
it all is it capcom sega take two from
soft disney tell it
okay i mean
they take to
take too strong if they can make that uh
grand theft
like like if you can see because you got
to look at the longevity of grand theft
auto 5 right
if you can make that exclusive on your
console and it can span generations
on that one console i think that yeah i
don't ever think anything's a death blow
right so not anymore
and saying that i don't think that's
true but i do say what can significantly
hurt them
is that yeah grand theft auto shout out
to conley put a tweet out and it had
grand theft auto 5 being released it's
the ps3 day ps4 and it each had a meme
of grand theft auto added a meme of a
different president for the everest that
it's come out grand theft auto has been
released all those times because yes
it's nuts
yeah for me it's disney i mean you get
disney you get you get star wars you get
marvel you get that that's insane mm-hmm
yeah
that's just crazy
we know that they won't buy this we
don't right now but in a weird world if
that ever happens
that would be monstrous
yeah like to have the whole star wars
still coming out oh yeah one superhero
game don't want you to alert
[Laughter]
i
i would love to see that then we got
heart needs to be again father i suggest
you five six confirmed multiple ps xbox
smash brothers killer instinct nope okay
i'll bend the knee to that that is the
case
but to say that playstation is not the
home of fighting games is erroneous
thanks
unless you just play smash you're
playing a fighting game on playstation
no doubt are we good i think we're
caught up all right finally we made it
thank
big show next sunday appreciate the
support again for all the last and media
people who are here i see you guys the
love is appreciated my brothers really
appreciate it you know you guys showing
me love's been tremendous and look we
got big things planning man iop is gonna
be fun the next month it's gonna be sick
more stuff
look into it we got some more giveaways
and we're getting close to 10k i
normally
the demand like buttons and all that
even though we should be doing that but
yeah spread the word because it really
does means a lot to us we're so close to
get that and when that that kind of
happens bigger things can happen for the
podcast big stacks and stuff like that
we get on a bigger profile we move up in
the algorithm so if you know about so
tell a friend tell a friend of the lords
you know 10k
we got a couple we got a couple
cedric h ten dollar super chat a doctor
strange game made by obsidian or ninja
theory making spawn
[ __ ] ninja five dollar super chat
phil about to be on his tupac i ain't
killed but don't push me
really quiet ones you gotta be out but
that's all i got we are out of here you
got anything else we're good
thank you guys appreciate it peace
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh